Hallo.
Ah, ich hab mich gemutet.
Omega, lol.
Wenn man schon in Twitch-Emotes spricht, dann kann man
immer ganz dicht sein, ne?
Sag mal,
ist irgendwas mit meiner Lautstärke?
Ich glaub, die irgendwie
spackt die Lautstärke rum, oder?
Ich mein,
wird da Mist eingestellt?
Vor allem, äh...
Ne, ich glaub,
die, ah ne, wobei,
ich glaub, ich seh laut, ha?
Ja, normalerweise, äh...
Ich teil hier im Stream...
Weiß ich nicht, wie laut ich sonst immer laber im Stream.
Windows stellt
den Krams ja irgendwie immer um.
Ich lass das jetzt mal auf 80, mal gucken.
Also, wenn's zu laut ist,
wenn es zu laut ist, dann, äh,
schmeiß ich's wieder weg.
Schauen wir mal.
Der Raketen-Karl! Pock, Alter!
Pock! Oh, jetzt kann ich mal gucken, wie laut es ist,
wenn ich sag, Pock! Boah, Pock ist zu...
Viel zu laut!
Ich bin lauter als sonst, ne?
Ja, Raketen-Karl.
Pock. Huge.
Und die Sound-Settings
haben sich voll verstellen, warte mal.
Das muss lauter.
Und das muss leiser.
Warum haben schnell Windows
den Krams immer um? Ich versteh das nicht.
Windows-Logik, äh...
So, jetzt, jetzt ist gut.
Könnte man den Discord-Bot so einstellen,
dass er gleich den Link zum Stream schickt?
Bestimmt, aber ich hab den Discord-Bot nicht...
äh...
...eingerichtet. Weiß es nicht.
Muss da Patrick oder das Ibarra oder irgendeiner machen.
Ja, danke für den Twitch-Prime-Sub.
Moment, ich muss mal ein Emote finden.
Reload. Reload, wo ist es?
Ist das ein Prime-Sub? Prime-Sub!
Grasser Shit.
Prime! Samus-Crimer!
Emotes haben sich auch verschoben.
Ich weiß nicht, was da kaputt ist da eigentlich.
Voll... voll failed gerade.
Übrigens, falls es euch noch nicht aufgefallen ist,
es gibt jetzt eine Sub-Badge,
die hat der mCore gestern zusammen gemacht.
Das ist die unkreativste Sub-Badge,
die man überhaupt haben kann.
Nur mal so angemerkt.
Es ist einfach der Keks.
Ohne etwas dabei.
Ich wollte ja noch andere Sachen machen,
aber ich hab gedacht, bevor es jetzt wieder so ewig dauert,
mach ich das erst mal rein.
Mach ich das erst mal rein,
und dann können wir immer noch gucken...
Ja genau, dann können wir immer noch gucken,
ob das passt.
Genau, besser als dieser Default...
Default-Prime-Stern.
Der Suckt.
Suckerino.
Der Stream-Wahnsinn.
Ja, weil, weil ein Stream auch so voll, voll wahnsinnig ist.
Da muss der xQc angucken,
wenn du den Stream-Wahnsinn haben willst.
Der springt dann mal einfach während dem Stream
auf seinen Stuhl und fliegt aufs Maul.
Wenn ich das machen würde,
hätte ich mir gleich den Arm gebrochen.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Also, ihr müsst jetzt mal in euch gehen,
und mir mal sagen,
ob ich die Lautstärke-Settings richtig eingestellt habe,
wie immer,
oder ob ich zu laut bin.
Ich glaube, zu leise bin ich nicht.
Eher bin ich einen Tick zu laut.
Hören tue ich das nicht,
weil mein Feedback,
also, dass ich mich selbst höre,
das geht über das Audio-Interface.
Da habe ich ja nichts umgestellt.
Nur Windows stellt den Kram immer um.
Das einzige, was ich gemacht habe, ist gestern,
ich habe Overwatch PTR installiert
und ein bisschen meine Windows-Sound-Settings hochgedreht.
Und schon stimmt die Streaming-Settings nicht mehr.
Kompletter Fail.
Sackt.
Sackt extrem.
Also, Leute.
Overwatch. Ja, guckt hier mal zum Beweis.
Ich habe es echt installiert.
Aber das Spiel wird es nicht.
Ich habe gestern zwei Runden gespielt.
Ich habe gestern zwei Runden Overwatch gespielt.
Habe festgestellt,
dass ich nicht nur schlecht geworden bin,
sondern extrem schlecht.
Und dann habe ich keinen Bock mehr gehabt.
Ich habe es sogar geschafft,
mit, was war das?
Nepal?
Nee, Lijiang Tower
mit Lucy runterzufallen.
Weil ich aus dem Spawn,
weil ich krass aus dem Spawn sliden wollte.
Und dann bin ich an der Raumschiffwand
weiter gesliden und runtergefallen.
So richtig Bronze.
Richtig Bronze.
So, vom letzten Stream.
Moment.
Warum ist das PP-Rabot nicht auf?
Ah, weil ich es nicht gestartet habe.
Wer hätte das denken können?
Läuft es auch nicht.
Jetzt sieht man auch gleich auf den ersten Blick
alle
Alle
Weil die alle so einen Keks haben.
Ja, Flamehaze.
Wir haben jetzt Sub-Badges.
Jetzt kannst du endlich subben.
Sellout-Modus aktiviert.
Ihr könnt euch ja mit Sicherheit noch
an die
Paketverfolgungs-App erinnern,
die wir programmiert haben.
Letzten Stream haben wir
MW2 angeguckt.
MW4 angeguckt.
Ich nenne es jetzt mal MW4.
Weil die Benamung mir jetzt
übelst wirr ist.
Bin free to watch.
Adblock on, never sub, never donate.
Free Entertainment.
Copypasta brauchst du jetzt nur noch.
Läuft das Ganze jetzt?
Ja, passt. Sehr schön.
Also mit Twitch Copypasta,
das macht mir keiner was vor.
Ich habe mittlerweile einen 800 Zeilen
Text-File
mit Twitch Copypastas.
Wir haben sogar extra im Discord
extra im Discord habe ich einen Channel gemacht,
wo
wo man die besten
von die besten Twitch Copypastas
reinhauen kann.
Ah, ne.
Hier, wichtig.
Und ganz wichtig,
der da. Running low on cuties.
Wenn Q-Chat
an ist.
Wer übrigens noch nicht auf dem Discord ist
und
joinen möchte, Ausrufezeichen Discord.
Neue IDE hattest du nicht immer
vorerst? Doch, doch, ich habe immer noch vorerst.
Das ist Rider unter Linux.
Weil wir haben ja dieses
das Chatlogboard
haben wir ja unter Linux gebastelt.
Soll ich euch mal
die Fortschritte vom Paket Tracker zeigen?
Der ist jetzt huge,
huge
beautiful Oberfläche, ey.
Der Paket Tracker.
Allerdings trackt er zur Zeit fake,
weil ich ja nur 250 API-Abfragen
für DHL habe und die beim Programmieren
instant weg wären.
Aber ich zeig doch mal den Fall.
Das SunTrack, so. Da ist er,
da ist er, da hat er die richtige Copypasta
rausgekriegt. Never sub, never donated,
Adblock on stone laptop,
neighbor's wifey, free entertainment.
Genau die Copypasta meine ich, ey.
Was da los?
Come on, bruh.
Direkt speichern
und in Discord Copypasta Channel
pasten.
Wichtig. Die müssen wir konservieren.
Ja, Knärbeer verstehe ich.
Der Knärbeer hat kein Geld.
Der muss OVL subben.
Dead game.
Warum startest du deine Tools eigentlich immer
über die E? Ja, eine gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung, eigentlich total bescheuert.
Total bescheuert.
Ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Du hast jetzt gesubbt und machst noch nicht mal
das Icon hin. Das ist ja noch mehr Fail.
Dead game.
Wir haben, ich seh grad noch,
wir haben noch zwei Fragen aus dem letzten Stream
offen und zwar
Wie schätzt du die Nützlichkeit von IT
Consultants ein?
Unterschiedlich nützlich schätze ich die ein.
Zum
größten Teil
also das Wort
Consultant hört sich ja so an, als konsultiert
man denjenigen zu irgendwas, was man selber nicht
kann. Das ist allerdings
selten der Fall. Meistens nimmt man das
einfach, wenn man irgendwelche Arbeitskräfte braucht
und gerade keine hat.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen,
es gab bisher noch kein Consultant,
der mir in den Bereichen, wo ich mich auskenne
was neues erzählen konnte.
Was aber auch okay ist, weil eigentlich würde man
einen Consultant dann holen, wenn man von einem bestimmten
Bereich keine Ahnung hat.
Ich
schätze die Nützlichkeit nicht
allzu hoch ein. Viele
Leute machen
das halt, also sagen wir mal so, es gibt
zwei Sorten von Consultants.
Es gibt einmal die Leute, die Consultant werden, weil sie
keine Ahnung haben. Zum Beispiel der
unser ehemaliger Special Azubi, das habe ich euch ja schon
mal erzählt im Stream, der
die IHK Prüfung mit Ach und Krach geschafft hat und
im dritten Lehrjahr quasi
nichts wusste. Der im dritten
Lehrjahr es nicht mal geschafft hat,
ein probliches Struktogramm zu malen,
Sinnhaftigkeit sei mal dahingestellt,
ein probliches Struktogramm zu malen
beziehungsweise mir zu erklären,
was passiert, wenn Rechner A zu
Rechner B einen Ping schickt. Das hat er im dritten
Ausbildungsjahr nicht hinbekommen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, gut,
das
ist jemand, der ist komplett planlos
und was ist er geworden? Junior Consultant.
Easy.
Und dann hat man natürlich noch die
Sorten Consultants, die sich wirklich
auskennen und eventuell auch mit den
anderen Sachen, die nicht so
gebräuchlich sind, die kann man dann auch wirklich so nennen.
DennisTheGamer96
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man da jetzt so
stolz drauf sein kann, dass man keine Ahnung
hat. Allerdings, es gibt ja
auch Leute, die, ich zitiere,
never sub, never donated,
adblock on stone, laptop, neighbors
wife, a free entertainment machen.
Das, wenn man sich zu der Gruppe
zählen will, das ist natürlich auch kein Problem.
Jetzt kommt, jetzt kommen hier die
Copybusters.
CuteChat.
Genau, soviel zu
IT-Consultants.
Und
dann haben wir noch eine Frage
von AnimaVestra.
Moin Max, hast du eigentlich schon mal
selbst Games programmiert, zum Beispiel
Unity? Nein, ich habe noch nie
Games programmiert und auch noch nicht
mit Unity. Das liegt hauptsächlich
daran, dass ich überhaupt keine
Game-Ideen habe.
Ja, wenn ich vielleicht irgendwelche
coolen Ideen, irgendwelche sinnvollen...
Musik ist ein bisschen leise. Könnte man jetzt wieder
ein bisschen lauter machen. Die weiß nicht so genau, was sie will.
Ja, jetzt ist besser.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Ideen,
was Games anbelangt.
Deswegen, wenn ich eine gute
Idee hätte, würde ich mir vielleicht auch mal überlegen.
Aber ich habe, wie gesagt, keinen Schimmer.
Ich bin da sehr unkreativ.
Früher, wo ich noch
kleiner war, habe ich mir immer gedacht,
ich würde gerne mal so ein eigenes
Zelda-Style-RPG machen,
weil ich halt der übelste Zelda-Fan war. Aber jetzt im Nachhinein
wüsste ich gar nicht, was ich da machen sollte,
was noch nicht schon mal gemacht wurde.
Und mir ist auch klar geworden, dass man Games
nicht programmiert, in dem Sinn.
Also, zu einem Game gehört noch viel, viel mehr
dazu. Da ist die Logik, die man programmiert,
ein Teil von. Aber alles
andere, was Sound, Animation und
Grafik angeht, bin ich eine totale Flasche drin.
Also, ich könnte den Teil
programmieren, aber ich bräuchte auf jeden Fall irgendjemand, der das
andere kann. Ein Shooter ohne Waffen,
ja. Ich mache so ein
Asset-Flip-Unity-Game. Oder,
ne, noch besser, so ein Asset-Flip
Unreal-Game, einfach in
Unreal-Store gehen,
ne Map runterladen und ein paar Häuser
draufstellen und dann easy streamen,
Greenlight.
Auf Steam kriegst du ja mittlerweile alles.
Ähm,
ein Pong-Spiel. Ich habe noch kein Game
programmiert. Kennt noch einer
das, das, das, das, das,
das Stampf-Game von Alt-F4-Games?
Das Stampf, in Anführungszeichen.
Game.
Das habe ich damals gebastelt, aber das ist kein Game.
Das besteht aus zwei Bildern.
Und
das Bild wechselt
auf Tastendruck. Also das ist kein Game.
Nein, ich habe noch kein Game
programmiert. Ähm.
Wenn du schon beim Thema bist,
wie funktioniert eigentlich,
wie funktioniert Ping eigentlich?
Muss dafür irgendein Port offen sein?
Basiert das auf TCP oder UDP?
Äh, weder noch.
Das ist ICMP, nennt sich das Ganze.
Die Apfelnudel ist auch da.
Moin. Äh, das ist weder TCP
oder UDP, das ist ICMP. Und ICMP
ist genau für solche Control-Messages gedacht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ganz sicher, was das für ein ICMP
äh, Type ist.
Ich glaube 22 und 23
oder sowas? Nee, 8.
0. 0 und 8.
Okay, nicht 22, 23,
was auch immer. Was war denn 22, 23?
Achso, äh, SSH
war 22 und 23, nee.
Warte mal. 23
23 SMTP, oder? Oder?
Ach, warum soll man sich so einen Blödsinn
merken auch? Ähm.
22 ist auf jeden Fall SSH.
Oder war 23 Telnet?
Nee, 25 SMTP.
Telnet-Port.
Was ist was denn?
23! Ja, 23 war Telnet.
Ah, weißt du.
Ein paar Sachen bleiben da noch hängen.
Ähm, tja. Also,
damit ist das, denke ich, beantwortet. Wie gesagt,
das ist ICMP, das ist ein eigenes
Protokoll. Das ist weder TCP
noch UDP.
Und, ähm,
das musst du in deiner Firewall genauso freischalten.
Wie alles andere auch.
Und wenn Ping erlaubt
sein soll, musst du einfach ICMP, äh,
erlauben. Und dann funktioniert das Ganze.
Äh, nach drei Monaten
habe ich noch Zeit.
Weil, ich habe jetzt erstmal
einen Sub-Batch reingemacht.
Ähm, damit überhaupt was drin ist.
Ähm.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich so machen. Entweder mache ich das wirklich
mit den Disketten oder, also nicht mit den Disketten,
mit den Discs.
Dass wir die in verschiedenen Farben machen, so von
Bronze, Gold, Platin, so. Irgendwie müsste das aber auch
irgendwie immer größer werden.
Ja. Oder was halt auch cool
wäre, wenn man unterschiedliche Hardware-Teile hätte.
Ja, also, äh,
ein Monat ist irgendwie eine Diskette.
Zwei Monate ist dann irgendwie, äh,
drei Monate ist dann irgendwie
sechs Monate ist
eine CPU. Irgendwie sowas. Oder aber
halt eine Diskette in unterschiedlichen, äh,
Farben oder so unterschiedlichen, äh,
von einer Bronze-Diskette
bis zur Platin-Diskette
oder den Keks in Schwarz-Weiß. Den Keks
in Gold. Irgendwas.
Ich, ich bin da, wie gesagt, ich bin da echt
nicht so sonderlich kreativ, was das angeht.
Äh, genau. Zwölf, zwölf Monate
gibt's dann eine NVMe-SSD.
Drei Monate Zip-Drive.
Zip-Drive. Kennt, kennt ihr das überhaupt noch?
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Die Dinger hier.
Hier. Die Teile.
Das Teil da. Zip-Drive.
Drei Drives in einem.
Expand your Hardware.
Drive Capacity with Unlimited.
Unlimited
Capacity. 100 MB.
Krass, ey. Unlimited.
Nice.
Ich glaube, jeder, der zur damaligen
Zeit, ähm, schon aktiv
war und, und Computer hatte,
der hatte dann ein bisschen später auch nen CD-Laufwerk
und ne CD, und dann
danach nen RW
CD-Brenner. Also wo man auch wieder
beschreibbare CDs reinmachen kann. Und jeder,
und ich glaube wirklich jeder, ist da
damals auf die Idee gekommen,
kann man nicht, dass
die RW-CD als Festplattenersatz
benutzen.
Es gab ja Programme, die das gemacht haben.
Also da konntest du quasi dein RW,
dein, dein RW, ähm,
CD-Laufwerk so einbinden,
dass es quasi für Windows ausgeschaut hat
wie ne, wie ne Festplatte.
Problem ist halt, dass das
unendlich langsam ist.
Zugriffszeiten und Schreibzeiten auf Doom,
äh, sind das gewesen.
Aber es hat jeder Ausbruch, es hat jeder Ausbruch.
Ich mein, zu ner Zeit, wo du irgendwie
ne Gig, ne Gig-Festplattenspeicher
hattest, oder zwei
Gig-Festplattenspeicher, da war halt so mal ne
650 MB CD.
Oder was ist Standard,
was ist die Standard-CD-Audiolänge
74 Minuten, gell?
74 Minuten.
Oder 64 Minuten?
Oder 72 Minuten?
Ach ja, äh, weil's da grad steht. Wisst ihr, warum,
äh, auf die, jetzt machen wir mal cool, cool
Storymarks. Wisst ihr, warum die ursprüngliche
CD 74 Minuten hatte?
Gut, ich mein,
wenn ich das jetzt so sage, ist blöd, man kann mal nachgucken.
Das war, weil ich glaube, Sony,
Sony war damals
der Meinung, sie müssten irgendeine Symphonie von
Beethoven veröffentlichen auf der ersten CD.
Und die war halt
nun mal so lang, komplett.
Deswegen ist die, deswegen ist die erste Audio-CD
irgendwie 74 Minuten.
Passt da drauf.
Classic. Musik.
CD. CD.
Ja.
Dauert 74 Minuten.
Genau, das ist das, was sie auf die CD
gepackt haben.
Big Brain. Wisst ihr Bescheid, ne?
Warum ist die Musik jetzt
auf einmal so laut?
Ich mag das nicht, wenn Streams
zwischendrin
das ändern.
Ich nehm was anderes.
Ja, ich guck immer, dass die Musik hier sich so,
so unter, unter der Hälfte ungefähr abspielt,
dass man das ordentlich raushört.
Da graus ich alles, ja.
Ja, das kann man im Hintergrund laufen lassen.
So. Der Informatiker
Underscore ist am Start. Pog.
Ähm.
Ja, ich zeige euch mal die neue Version von
meinem Versand-Tracker.
Der ist jetzt ein bisschen advancer geworden.
Ich hab da nämlich gestern noch ein bisschen dran rumgebaut.
Am Sonntag. Und zwar,
ich starte das ganze Ding jetzt mal.
Weil, ihr seht, wie poggert das mit.
Ich hoffe, er kackt das nicht ab.
Ach, das ist Absicht.
Das ist Absicht. Das ist ne Acception,
die werfe ich, das ist Absicht, ja.
.NET wirft
keine Acception in der Plub drinnen steht.
Das ist von mir.
Das ist zum Testen, dass es nicht abkackt, wenn ne Acception wirft.
Wenn ich ne Acception werfe.
Ich hab ein bisschen umgebaut ohne euch.
Ne, ich hab nicht umgebaut. Ich hab ein bisschen den Webinterface rumgeschraubt.
Ein paar Sachen gemacht. Also, passt mal auf.
Ähm.
Wir starten das jetzt mal.
Wartet sich das jetzt nicht?
Achso. Weil wir Visual Studio nicht aufhaben.
Äh, Visual Studio Code.
Und wir hier noch über den Dev-Server gehen.
Den brauchen wir jetzt eh gleich.
Nur ruhig den Dev-Server starten.
Und darüber machen das Ganze.
So.
Also.
An der Tabelle muss man auch ein bisschen arbeiten, ja.
Lustigerweise, ich hab's mir
nur so angeguckt. Und so sieht das echt ganz gut aus.
Ja.
Also, was wir jetzt da haben ist.
Ich mach mal Fullscreen.
Das muss man ein bisschen schlank machen.
Ich glaub die Tabelle brauchen wir eh nicht.
Und hier oben, das kommt dann auch
in die Leiste rein. Aber guck mal.
Also, wir haben jetzt schon mal wieder einmal
was natürlich ganz ganz tolle ist.
Dark, Dark und äh.
Light Theme. Das braucht man.
Äh, Beat Pro, die kommen auf dem alten Kanal.
Aber wann, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich brauch erstmal überhaupt ein ordentliches Konzept dahinter.
So. Ähm.
Wir haben ein Dark & Light Theme. Ganz wichtig.
Ich mach mal kurz das Zeug da oben weg.
Das irritiert.
Ähm. Weg hier.
So.
Jetzt ist es doch viel schöner.
Splitten wir das mal. So.
Ähm. So. Und da seht ihr es hier schon.
Man kann es jetzt ausklappen.
Ja. Also.
Du hast jetzt hier drinnen stehen.
Aktuell was für ein Provider das ist.
Also was für ein Paket. Versandgut.
Ähm.
Dann hast du hier oben die Trackingnummer
drin stehen. Und wenn du drauf klickst.
Du siehst immer den aktuellsten Stand
vom Paket. Hier hat er noch nichts abgerufen.
Hier, da ist es da. Du hast das passende
Icon dazu.
Die Sub Badges kamen vor 5 Minuten oder 10 Minuten
bevor ich den Stream angemacht habe.
Wenn man hier drauf klickt. Ist richtig huge.
Kriegst du hier angezeigt.
Die History von deinem Paket.
Also was er
von DHL abgerufen hat hier.
Das ist doch nice.
Oder?
Wenn du hier unten drauf klickst. Kriegst du von dem Paket angezeigt.
Wenn du da drauf klickst.
Kriegst du von dem Paket angezeigt.
Wenn du da drauf klickst. Hat er nichts.
Huge. Ja.
Übrigens alles ist Fake Trackingnummer.
Die gibt es nicht. Die gibt es nicht.
Die 2 gibt es.
2 Stück gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Trackingnumbers.
Man sollte den Paketen
auch Namen geben können.
Ich habe mir das eh überlegt.
Die
Tabelle ist eh relativ sinnlos.
Ich habe mir gedacht. Wir können das nämlich so machen.
Dass man hier neben dann einfach
die Buttons hat für löschen und editieren.
Und wenn man den Edit Button drückt.
Kann man auch irgendwie so einen Comment
machen.
Der Name hin ist schwierig.
Ich habe ja keine Ahnung was das für ein Paket ist.
Ich weiß ja nicht ob es von Amazon ist oder sowas.
Tommy sagt.
Ohne irgendwie beleidigend zu sein.
Anzeige direkt.
Welchen Vorteil hat es.
Das zu den einfachen
Paketverfolgungen benutzen.
Die es schon mehrfach gibt.
Das hat mehrere Vorteile.
Ich glaube ich habe es mal irgendwann auch im Stream erklärt.
Was das ganze eigentlich geben soll.
Erstens hast du alle Anbieter in Deutschland
inklusive Amazon auf einen Blick.
Und Amazon
können die wenigsten dieser komischen
der ganzen
Paketverfolgungs Apps.
Ähm
Dann hast du Integration in deine
Heimautomatisierung.
Also sprich du kannst da auch drauf reagieren.
Wenn ein Paket anrückt.
Da kannst du irgendwie
was auch immer damit machen.
Du weißt das.
Was für Benachrichtigungen schicken lassen.
Wenn ein Paket ankommt.
Egal von welchem Anbieter.
Und was für Benachrichtigungssachen wir da einbauen.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Auf Discord oder MQTT.
Alle möglichen Sachen.
Und der eigentliche Knackpunkt.
Der eigentliche Witz an der Sache ist ja.
Das ist dein E-Mail Postfach scant.
Was du einträgst.
Nach neuen Trackingnummern.
Das heißt du musst die Trackingnummer
gar nicht von Hand hinzufügen.
Du kriegst eine Mail.
Vom Shop geschickt.
Der dir dann sagt.
Ihre Sendung wurde verschickt.
Das klingt ehrlich gesagt.
Ziemlich nach Aftership.
Es gibt ein paar Anbieter die sowas schon machen.
Ein paar Anbieter die sowas schon machen.
Aber die kosten in der Regel alle Geld.
Und.
Man muss seine E-Mail weiterleiten.
An Leute die man nicht kennt.
Du weißt die.
Du weißt das gar nicht.
Was man machen könnte ist.
Wenn man hinzufügt.
Übrigens.
Falls das jemand jetzt.
Die letzte Minute wäre nice.
Wenn das jemand klippen könnte.
Dann könnten wir das nämlich nehmen.
Für die Erklärung.
Wieso Tobi.
Du kannst es doch bei dir laufen lassen.
Es ist doch ein Unterschied.
Ob du deine E-Mail zu einem Anbieter schickst.
Wo du es nur bei dem verwenden kannst.
Wenn du nur bei dem.
Seinen Cloud Service verwenden kannst.
Oder ob du es bei dir laufen lassen kannst.
Ich dachte es gibt auch lokale Programme.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich mein.
Paket Tracker ist jetzt nichts sonderlich ausgefallenes.
In dem Sinn.
Genau.
Und außerdem lernt man was beim Selbstbasteln.
Ja also was man machen könnte mit der Nummer ist.
Wenn man das hinzufügt.
Ich weiß ja an der Stelle nicht.
Welche Nummer.
Was ist.
Also in der Sendeverfolgung krieg ich das nicht mit.
Guck mal hier.
In der Sendeverfolgung steht es ja nicht drin.
Also in der Sendeverfolgung steht sowas drin.
Wie.
Kommt aus Deutschland.
Geht nach Deutschland.
Wiegt so und so viel.
Und die Zwischenstation mit Adresse.
So was man jetzt machen könnte ist.
Ähm.
APK Leak.
Ja ich weiß.
Der APK haben wir zusammen live im Stream erstellt.
Da gibt es nichts zu leaken.
Webhooks.
Können wir alles einbauen.
Das ist ja das schöne daran.
Zeig mal wie du das Dropdown gemacht hast.
Kann ich gleich machen.
Nicht die hohe JavaScript Kunst die ich da fabriziert habe.
Also was wir machen können.
Wegen der Tracking Nummer.
Es gibt ja zwei Varianten.
Wie man eine Tracking Nummer in das Programm kriegt.
Und zwar.
Einmal.
Von Hand eintragen.
Dann kann man ja einen Kommentar dazu posten.
Also das heißt.
Das können wir gleich mal hier reinschreiben schon.
Das wir sagen.
Wir brauchen hier noch.
Ups.
Schauen wir mal aus.
Das andere zeige ich gleich.
Also das heißt.
Wir brauchen schon mal was.
Für.
Comment.
Was nu.
Fenster aus.
Welchen Gründen auch.
Immer.
Wir brauchen sowas wie einen Comment.
Das könnte man dann eingeben.
Wenn man das Ding anlegt.
So.
Und sollte er den Kram aus der E-Mail.
Oder woanders rausfischen.
Die Tracking Nummer.
Dann könnte man den Absender der E-Mail reinschreiben.
In das Comment.
Das wäre doch mal was.
Wenn er beispielsweise das E-Mail Postfach durchsucht.
Und feststellt.
Aha es gibt eine neue Tracking Nummer.
Und das ist eine Tracking Nummer.
Für sagen wir DHL.
Dann merkt er sich die Tracking Nummer.
Und im Kommentarfeld.
Ich meine das kann man ja nachher noch ändern.
Ist ja okay.
Wenn man das von Hand anpassen will.
Und man könnte in das Comment.
Könnte man dann quasi.
Entweder den Teil aus dem.
Aus dem Betreff von der E-Mail nehmen.
Oder den Absender.
Oder die Absender Domain das Interessanteste.
Die Absender Domain.
Dürfte das Interessanteste sein.
Weil die Absender Domain ist immer so.
Quasi Amazon.com oder bei irgendeinem Online Shop.
Dann halt keine Ahnung.
Blumen 2000.
Irgendwas.
Oder Alternate oder sowas.
Als Domain.
Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Idee.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Zeig doch mal.
So jetzt zeige ich mal wie ich das Dropdown gemacht habe.
Also das Dropdown funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Also wenn man jetzt hier drauf klickt.
Dann kommt ja hier so ein Dropdown.
Zu der jeweiligen Sendung.
Was da als Status drin ist.
Und.
Wie ich das gemacht habe.
Ist.
Die jeweilige Tabellen.
Die Tabelle.
Die Zelle hier.
Von der Tabelle.
Hat ein Klick Event.
Und wenn ich da drauf klicke.
Ruft es die Funktion auf.
Und dann kann ich.
Auf die habe ich.
Die hier heißt Expand.
Und übergibt das aktuelle.
Die aktuellen Infos.
Was das halt für ein Paket ist.
Expand macht nicht sonderlich viel.
Außer es zu setzen.
Und beim nächsten Klick wieder zu löschen.
Und er guckt einfach nach.
Wenn das das.
Feld ist.
Wo ich reingeklickt habe.
Dann gibt er einfach hier die komplette History aus.
Filter History.
Filter History guckt.
Ist das das Feld was ich angeklickt habe.
Dann rendere ich die komplette History an der Stelle.
Ist das das Feld.
Ist es ein anderes Feld.
Dann rendere ich nur die erste.
Den letzten Eintrag von der History.
Also das ist.
Recht.
Einfach.
Wann hast du das alles gemacht?
Gestern.
Es ist ja nur ein bisschen CSS Spielerei im Endeffekt.
Die Infos waren ja alle schon da.
Hat das das beantwortet?
Oder willst du das noch ein bisschen genauer wissen?
Wir können uns das ruhig noch mal ein bisschen genauer angucken.
Wie hast du das mit dem Dark Mode gemacht?
Ist das eine Funktion von Vue?
Ne.
Das ist CSS Variable.
Das ist jetzt was neues.
Kannst hier oben.
Kannst du eine Klasse definieren.
Light Mode, Dark Mode.
Wie die heißt ist egal.
Kannst du auch Omega Lull Mode.
Und Hyper Lull Mode nennen.
Da definierst du halt deine Variablen drin.
Was die halt.
Hier Background hat das da.
Wenn es Light Mode ist Background das da.
So.
Und dann stellst du hier bei deiner App.
Bei deinem Root Element.
Stellst du ein.
Als Klasse.
Das ist jetzt Vue Syntax.
Aber das kannst du auch mit normalem JavaScript machen.
Da stellst du einfach ein.
Bei deinem Root Element.
Wenn Dark Mode gesetzt ist.
Dann weist dem Ding die Klasse Dark Mode zu.
Wenn nicht Dark Mode gesetzt ist.
Dann weist dem Ding die Klasse Light Mode zu.
Und dann machst du einen Knopf.
Wo du das zwischendrin umschaltest.
Und der Rest macht CSS.
Weil guck an jeder Stelle wo ich hier.
Irgendwelche Farben bei CSS verwende.
Ähm.
Habe ich jetzt einfach hier.
Als Variable drinne.
Dementsprechend nimmt er jedes mal.
Je nachdem was das Root Element für eine Klasse hat.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen.
Ich finde Light sieht es fast noch besser aus.
So und das müssen wir jetzt allerdings.
Einhauen weil das sieht kacke aus.
Wenn das da oben so rumhängt.
Das Light ist tatsächlich recht dezent das Light.
Dadurch das es grau ist.
Man kann natürlich immer noch löschen das Zeug.
Man sieht hier wann zuletzt geupdatet wurde.
Wie gesagt.
Aktuell mache ich so.
Ich schreibe einfach beim Start.
Ein paar Fake Werte rein.
Weil ich ja mit dem Tracker für DHL.
Plus 250 Aufrufe am Tag habe.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus.
Das ähm.
UPS Hermes.
Die haben ja keine AP das UPS.
Und DPD auch nicht viel mehr Aufrufe zulassen.
Standardmäßig.
Über ihre AP als eben.
250.
Die DHL AP erlaubt mehr.
Da muss man sich aber registrieren.
Und anmelden mit seiner App und sowas.
Mache ich vielleicht mal.
Wenn das Ding ja soweit fertig ist.
Ich finde den stylischen Farbverlauf.
Von Orange zu Grün.
Im Hintergrund vor den Icon.
Nice.
250 Aufrufe am Tag.
Reicht doch für eine Einzelperson.
Ja die Sache ist bloß die.
Wenn das dann mehr als einer benutzt.
Dann reicht das.
Relativ schnell nicht.
Und normalerweise.
Sagt man ja man sollte keine AP Keys mit ausliefern.
Allerdings in dem Fall.
Ist halt so.
Es hat keiner Bock.
Sich erstmal.
4 AP Keys zu erstellen.
Damit man das benutzen kann.
Den Backup Tracker.
Den wir abfragen.
Das heißt.
Wenn die AP Keys irgendwie aufgebraucht sind.
Oder rumschmacken.
Oder einer keinen Bock hat.
Sich einen eigenen AP Key zu generieren.
Dann kann er den Backup Tracker nehmen.
Ja das ist nicht so einfach.
Das ist.
Ziemlicher CSS Hack.
Dass der Strich da im Hintergrund überhaupt funktioniert.
Der 0 nach 15 User.
Ist zu blöd sich den AP Key zu generieren.
Wenn du den Leuten sagst.
Geh da mal hier auf DHL Seite.
Ins Entwickler Portal.
Mach dir einen AP Key.
Geh mal bei UPS einen AP Key machen.
Das checkt keiner.
Ich habe mir schon überlegt.
Wie ich es irgendwie machen könnte.
Dass ich einen AP Key mit ausliefer.
Ob ich den da irgendwie.
Verschlüsselt rein encode.
Oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Es geht mir gar nicht so sehr darum.
Ähm.
Die meisten Anbieter sagen.
Man darf den AP Key nicht im Klartext ausliefern.
Deswegen werde ich den wahrscheinlich.
So Fake mäßig verschlüsselt einbauen.
Und da kann keiner sagen.
Ich liefere es im Klartext aus.
Ja.
So ungefähr habe ich mir das auch vorgestellt.
Wenn das Ding fertig ist.
Registriere ich mich halt einmal.
Bei UPS, DPD, DHL, Hermes.
Und Döns.
Mache mir einen.
Kostenlosen.
Developer Account.
Da sind dann wahrscheinlich 1000 Abfragen am Tag.
Und den liefere ich dann halt.
Verschlüsselt mit aus.
Wie gesagt.
Man darf ihn halt meistens nicht im Klartext reinschreiben.
Und.
Wenn es halt aufgebraucht ist.
Dann ist es aufgebraucht.
Allerdings muss man sagen.
Es dürfte sich in Grenzen halten.
Weil ich sage mal so.
Wenn man den Abfrageintervall auf eine Stunde macht.
Da können das trotzdem ein paar Leute verwenden.
Bis das aufgebraucht ist.
Wo ist denn das ein CSS Hack?
Ich finde das ist schon ein ziemlicher CSS Hack.
Ähm.
Dass man damit eine Linie im Hintergrund mal da.
Was da.
Ich finde das nicht so offensichtlich.
Wie das geht.
Was da hier im Hintergrund.
Naja Leute.
Also so viel zum.
Versandtracker.
Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht so genau was wir heute machen.
Also ich hätte.
Ein paar Sachen zur Auswahl was wir machen können.
Vielleicht machen wir.
Ich mache einfach auch alles davon.
Brauche ich mal eine Textdatei.
Du kannst ja Community Loadbalancing einbauen.
Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht was für dich genau.
Community.
Oh ja.
Hab ich hier.
Guck da ist er.
Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht genau was du meinst.
Du kannst ja Community Loadbalancing einbauen.
Was meinst du damit?
Also was ich mir überlegt habe ist.
Wir liefern einfach nicht ein APK mit.
Sondern.
Ähm.
Wir registrieren uns einfach mit.
10 Fake E-Mails.
Und machen ein APK.
Ja okay.
Das ist schon ein bisschen komplizierter.
Ähm.
Was man machen könnte ist.
Was ich mir auch schon überlegt habe ist. Ähm.
Müsste ich die Request irgendwie Proxien.
Da habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Oder aber ich mache so.
Dass mein Programm beim Start halt.
Von meinem Server halt.
Ein APK abfragt.
Der noch gültig ist.
Und ähm.
Den dann halt im Speicher behält bis zum Neustart.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Muss ich mir mal Gedanken zu machen.
Machst du auch GLS TNT die ganzen Firmen rein.
Wenn die eine ordentliche API dafür haben.
Kann ich das machen.
Bisher habe ich bloß so die üblichen Verdächtigen geplant.
Weil ich halt selbst verwenden will.
Für meine Pakete zu tracken.
Mit die die von Amazon.
Oder von Alternate oder so kommen.
Stimmt wir wollten uns da Stack Overflow Survey ein.
Jetzt.
Da habe ich ganz vergessen.
Endlich Feierabend Lell.
Lell ist total out.
Das sagt man immer.
Das ist genau so wie man nicht mehr Alter sagt.
Oder Alder.
Sondern Digger sagt man auch nicht mehr.
Digger, Digger.
Ich habe jetzt gehört man sagt Bruder.
Aber Bruder kann man doch überhaupt nicht cool aussprechen.
Oder?
Alter.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber wie sagst du denn Bruder?
Brudi.
Auf Ehre.
Bru.
Bro.
Das ist mir zu dumm.
Ich kann doch nicht zu Leuten die ich nicht kenne.
Noch nie gesehen habe.
Ey Bruder.
Auf Ehre.
Bruder.
Ich weiß nicht das hört sich irgendwie.
Ich finde das blöd an.
Naja okay.
Wir wollten uns das Stack Overflow.
Die Stack Overflow Umfrage 2019 angucken.
Die Entwickler Umfrage 2019.
Ähm.
So ein bisschen größer machen.
Also was haben sie mit der Umfragt.
Also was die ja jedes Jahr machen.
Ist ja so nach dem Motto.
Was sind die Programmiersprachen mit denen ihr arbeitet.
Und ähm.
Was sind die Programmiersprachen und Technik.
Die euch gefällt.
Mal gucken ob die.
In den letzten Jahren haben sie dann auch noch ein paar Umfragen gehabt.
Irgendwie ähm.
Weibliche Entwickler, männliche Entwickler und sowas.
Mal gucken ob sie das dieses Jahr ausgebaut haben.
Da muss ich wieder aufpassen.
Wenn ich jetzt das Falsche sage.
Kommen wieder die Feministen und regen sich auf.
Ist äh.
Instant die Anzeige raus.
Jo fellow kids Bruder.
Jo.
So was von hängen geblieben.
Das kann ich nicht ernsthaft im Stream sagen.
Kann viel Blödsinn im Stream erzählen.
Aber das ist so Fremdschäme.
Direkt mal ein Kartoss.
Ja.
Gibt es eigentlich für Stack Overflow einen Dark Mode?
Dark Mode.
So.
War Stylish nicht das wo mal eine Trojaner eingebaut war?
Da war doch was.
Da war doch mal was.
Ja genau.
Ach ne.
Die haben irgendwelche Tracking Software eingebaut.
Das wars.
Moin Patrick.
Das wars. Die haben es aus dem Store entfernt.
Weil die irgendwelche Sachen getrackt haben.
Das installiere ich mir nicht mehr.
Die haben es.
Die haben es verkackt.
Das ist so geil.
Diese Statements sind immer so geil.
Es wurde aus dem Store entfernt.
Wegen Bedenken was Privatsphäre angeht.
Und der erste Satz ist.
We care about your privacy.
Ah.
Es passt. Das klingt immer so toll.
So nach dem Motto.
Wir haben alle unsere Benutzer verarscht.
Und dann kommt als Antwort dann immer sowas wie.
Benutzerzufriedenheit ist unser höchstes Ziel.
Darkreader macht wirklich alle Seiten dark.
Was sagst du hier Darkreader?
Willst du gebannt werden oder was?
Anzeige ist raus. Gibt es nicht hier.
Das war typischer Twitch.
Twitch Blödsinn.
Night Eye App.
Okay.
Dark Mode Extension.
Protect your eyes.
Okay.
Was macht das? Mal angucken.
Subemote. Ja gibt es jetzt.
Keine Emotes.
Keine Subscriber.
Oder wie das Twitch auf Deutsch nennt.
Ein Abonnenten Treue Abzeichen.
Okay wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Free Forever Pill.
Okay ich installiere mir das jetzt mal.
Und das funktioniert.
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht geguckt was die Extension für ne...
Wir removen das mal kurz.
Ich habe gar nicht geguckt was die Extension von mir will.
Ach easy.
Da birgt der überhaupt keine Gefahren.
Oh Subscriber.
Twitch Prime.
Subscriber.
Wen haben wir denn da.
Den....
Max, Max Echse, verleadspeakter Max, schreibweise.
Max Echse, Poggers, danke schön, Twitch Prime.
Aber okay, guck mal, die Seite sieht doch ganz hübsch aus, Dark.
3 for free?
Moment, das kostet was?
Und wie kann ich jetzt sagen, ich will es für diese Webseite nicht aktivieren?
Ein Streamer, der meinen Namen...
Bin Leadspeak erprobt.
Und, ähm, kann man das jetzt ausschalten hier oben?
Haltet man das jetzt aus?
Ah, da unten ist so ein ganz fetter Knopf.
Moment, war das Bild schon immer so?
Ja, okay, das Bild war schon immer so dunkel.
Also ich muss sagen, ähm, ich muss sagen, das sieht ganz gut aus, wie das Addon das macht.
Gut lesbar.
Warum wollen die jetzt Geld dafür haben?
Ist das hier dimm?
Ach, cool.
Cool.
Too light.
Das ist hier, ähm, dass man abends das mehr Gelb hat.
Finde ich nice.
Und warum soll man das jetzt...
Expires?
Warum soll man das jetzt kaufen?
Warum soll man das jetzt genau kaufen?
Echt, T-Way?
Warum soll man das kaufen?
Oh!
Subscribers!
Haben wir wieder.
Der Knärbär.
Ja, erstmal auf, unsubscribed und maxsubscribed.
So mag ich das.
Fuck.
Ja, wir kaufen hier keine Addons.
Ich dachte doch, free entertainment, never sub, adblock on.
Ähm, wen haben wir jetzt noch hier?
Der Schniedelwutz.
Bist du verwandt mit Tigerwutz?
War schlecht.
Wobei, Tigerwutz hat, äh, hat's mit seinem Schniedelwutz ja auch ein bisschen übertrieben.
Ich, ich, ich, keine, keine Witze mehr.
Ist gut.
Äh, kaufen.
Warum, warum soll man das kaufen?
Okay, was hat er gesagt?
Für Darkreader.
Darkreader.
Darkreader Chrome.
Chrome.
Die sprechen, die sprechen eigentlich, die sprechen eigentlich Japaner Google Chrome aus.
Die sprechen das doch bestimmt Chrome oder so aus.
Chrome.
Die mögen doch so, ähm, so Vokale am Ende.
Äh, hier.
Extensions, okay, dann machen wir das mal den, den da wieder aus.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken.
Night Eye.
Ich muss erstmal schauen.
Warum, warum die Geld wollen.
Das, das...
das habe ich nicht genau gecheckt preis kann man es denn kaufen überhaupt und
warum wollen geld forever free plan die vorgehung night wie ein pro die sollten
mal genauer erklären war was was das was das ausmacht also warum man sich pro
kaufen sollte so genau hier haut und installiert wie das ist ich schon mit
der kostenlosen extension dann auch okay da krieger probiert mal aus da krieger
reader
da ist langsamer gefühlt er ist langsamer als der andere ansonsten sehe ich jetzt gar
nicht so viel unterschied ehrlich gesagt
was nach drei monaten funktioniert es nur auf fünf webseiten egal wir haben jetzt ewig
lang rum gebastelt mit komischen chrome extensions ich finde ich finde ich ganz
nice das ist jetzt mal drinnen menschen zwar hier mal den den den zeit einmal wieder weg
wie schaltet man den aus auf also guck mal das aktuelle stack auch die aktuelle
aktuelles deck overflow entwickler umfrage an was da cheeseешьor ne stunde
warum bin ich schon eine stunde und was warumatos earth vor simply markt
fragt ob die
겨
bell
willstej
ab
um
das st können sie tun und вкусael
listめ Оruch
value
specialists inside reliability engineers sind am höchsten bezahlt dass das ist gut für mich
das ist gut für mich da freue ich mich da müssen wir gleich noch ein paar job angebote nachher
wieder angucken ok bla bla bla developer roles also wie verteilt sich das ganze developer types
also 51 prozent ich gehe mal davon an dass man mehrere sachen ankreuzen durfte hören weil
ansonsten sind wir über 100 prozent das ergibt ja irgendwie einen sinn also übernachtet man
dürfte wahrscheinlich mehrere sachen ankreuzen also sagen 51 prozent 52 prozent den full stack
50 back end 32 frontend ja so ich würde mich auch viel eher da dazu zählen als frontend ich
meine wie gesagt habt ihr hier gesehen ich kriege ich kriege ein bisschen
bisschen mehr als ich habe es ja gesehen ich kriege ich kriege ein bisschen mehr als ich habe
ein bisschen ein bisschen was gebacken frontend javascript mit ich habe nichts
gesagt warum hat sich das jetzt verschoben habe ich kaputt gemacht man darf die seite
bloß nicht zu groß machen sobald man die seite zu groß macht das ist kein bug das
ist einfach nur responsive alles absicht responsive
aber ich bin weit davon entfernt der übelste css und und html css pro zu sein also ich habe
mich auch eher als ich würd mich auch zu full stack zählen somitoweile표 wenn wie gesagt wir
machen beckern sieht man ja im stream im endeffekt wir machen beckern sachen wir machen front end
sachen wir machen eigentlich alles möglich ja wir haben alle möglichen sachen schon gemacht
ich meine wie gesagt ich bin weit davon entfernt der übelste css und html css pro zu sein so das
gibt es meistens als folgs Volker Bosch klar sagtойann we're doing all the drums we're gonna do companies
that we have you can do it so man saying all of us cooperates we're gonna throw some of those in this but yeah
we're not supposed to count those but I am starts in class which is why I think most of us Musik
alles möglich wir haben alle möglichen sachen schon gemacht im stream und ein
bisschen frontend schadet keinem was wenn man sich ein bisschen überlegt okay
wie wird es am ende denn angezeigt was ist vollstack ja im prinzip kombination
aus frontend und backend also du kennst dich mit beidem ganz gut aus und
mit ein bisschen was dazwischen vielleicht kennst du dich auch noch ein
bisschen mit ein bisschen mit dem prinzip system aus wo das ganze
drauf läuft oder sowas nach einem monat hardcore css und du bist der profi drin
der stimmt jedes mal wenn ich ein bisschen ein bisschen länger wenn ich
ein projekt habe wo ich ein bisschen was frontend mäßiges machen muss hier zum
beispiel versand tracker oder sowas in dem wir jetzt ich habe es irgendwie ich
habe es kaputt gemacht ach das läuft überhaupt nicht deswegen ist das kaputt
gemacht
, oder? doch das läuft und ich habe ich habe irgendwas ganz heftig kaputt gemacht
ach das addon macht das nicht das addon macht das nicht oder? omega lul das ist das addon
lul hier das fail geil weiß nicht mehr was ich sagen wollte ach so man kann das nicht nur
für spezielle seiten an und ausschalten doch das muss doch gehen die
video
wie es zeit lässt jetzt ja wie gesagt ein bisschen bisschen frontend zeug
kriegen und wenn ich ihn ich merke das immer selbst wenn ich eine zeit lang am
stück weil ich frontend sachen machen muss dann css rumbasteln dann weil dann
kenne ich auch mehr auch bis javascript genaues problem ist wenn man das nicht
konsistent macht oder nicht konstant macht vergisst man so mäßig viel gehört
php zu frontend oder zu backend php gehört zu backend php ist eindeutig
backend
wir reden jetzt mal nicht von diesen komischen php seiten wo quasi er hat hier
im mpp alles in einem ist aber das php eines beckert ich meine vortritt ist alles
das was im browser läuft ein eingang eingestellt und billion probierte backend
ja und jetzt hier ich weiß jetzt sagt er nichts die hava script dann muss man
halt bejahzt ist ein bisschen genauer unterscheiden
ist es das java schrift was im browser läuft oder ist es java schriftразum isanic
des enormous collaboration alsEE attının bei dens 서ure ich weiß jetzt sagt der nächste javascript dann muss man hat bei java skript bisschen genau unterscheiden ist es das javascript was im browser läuft oder ist es javascript was auf dem background läuft also Ellie aus dem soiade und soiade und hier sagt sich zu al 기본 env inlet the app editor also kill yok
anläuft wobei die mit den neuen web assembly geschichten verschwimmt das
ganze ein bisschen wir haben uns ja letztens im streamer blazer angeguckt
also quasi das dotnet von microsoft für den browser dass das web assembly dotnet
also die es ist natürlich immer noch klar was server ist und was frontend ist
aber es verschwimmt so ein bisschen durch die geschichte dadurch dass man
quasi dann auch c sharp oder c++ oder c quasi im browser machen kann
sowas macht ja keiner der noch bei verstand ist was da ist da gerade im
chat mit php steht ich bin nicht der super krasse php owner also ich habe
wenig mit php gemacht einzige bisschen größere was man mit php gemacht habe in
den letzten jahren ist stats und profil seite für meinen battlefield server
und das habe ich halt auch nur in php gemacht mit mit lera welle damals php
gemacht weil halt eben jeder popel haus der php dabei hat okay guck mal was das
ganze mal weiter an also full stack würde ich mittlerweile auch dazu zählen
man muss ja nicht alles perfekt können backend frontend krieg ich auch noch
gebacken wie gesagt hier würde ich mich nicht als
experte irgendwie sehen von angeht developer desktop oder enterprise applications
applications
ja nicht wirklich die sachen die ich auf der arbeit mache das ist das interne
tools nicht teil unserer eigentlichen anwendungen die dann der außendienst
development mobile da muss ich sagen ich würde gerne mehr mobile zeug machen
einfach um das mal ein bisschen anzugucken ich habe so gut wie nichts
mobile gemacht bisher das einzige was ich bisher mobile gemacht habe ist ich
habe mal versucht
ein paar progressive Web-Apps laufen zu lassen
und festgestellt, dass die Unterstützung bei Apple übelst für den Arsch ist.
Was ist nach deiner Erfahrung der beste Lieferant in Deutschland,
also Hermes, DHL oder UPS?
Ja, wenn du mich als Käufer fragst,
bin ich immer froh, wenn die Sachen per DHL verschickt werden.
Es ist regional ein bisschen unterschiedlich,
aber ich persönlich finde DHL immer am stressfreiesten.
Probleme gibt es mit allen ab und zu, aber DHL funktioniert gut.
DHL hat überall Abholstationen, wunderbar.
Was auch ganz cool ist mittlerweile,
wenn man so eine Amazon-Station um die Ecke hat,
es gibt ja mittlerweile komplett eigene Amazon-Packstationen,
aus Sicht von jemandem, der Sachen verschickt, weiß ich es nicht.
Was ist aus dem Paket-Tracker geworden? Ja, da ist er.
Da ist er, der Paket-Tracker.
Bisschen hübscher gemacht mittlerweile.
Bisschen hübscher gemacht.
Und...
Wir hatten das gerade gefragt.
Der Boss der FTW,
du hast mittlerweile auch eine History drin.
Und es sieht natürlich schöner aus.
Du hast sogar unterschiedliche Statussymbole,
wo das gerade ist.
Hier ist es im Auto, wird geliefert.
Hier ist es noch auf dem Weg zu einem
und hier ist es angekommen.
Ist natürlich bei weitem noch nicht fertig.
Da kann man noch ewig dran rumbasteln.
Haben wir wenigstens im Stream auch was zu tun.
Ja, also wenn ich mal was mobile ausprobieren würde,
so richtig ausprobieren,
richtig mobile, jetzt keine PWA-Geschichte,
dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich wirklich auch mal zum Anlass nehmen,
mir Flutter anzugucken.
Das würde ich mir mal angucken.
Weil es geht ja, wenn ich irgendwas mobile-mäßig mache,
wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht darum gehen,
dass ich eine App basteln will,
die ich wirklich releasen möchte in App Store,
sondern einfach zum Ausprobieren.
Und dann würde ich mal wirklich Flutter ausprobieren.
Das ist ja schwer im Kommen.
Es ist halt noch recht neu.
Ein paar Sachen wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht dafür geben.
Was ich ganz cool finde und warum ich mir auch schon überlegt habe,
man müsste sich eigentlich mal Flutter angucken,
weil das wohl auch immer mehr im Kommen ist,
dass jetzt Desktop als Plattform unterstützt wird.
Und vielleicht haben wir es ja mit Flutter oder vielleicht schaffen sie es ja mit Flutter
mal wirklich ein ordentliches GUI-Framework zu kreieren,
dass man wirklich auf allen verbreiteten Desktops und Mobile-Geräten einsetzen kann.
Das wäre natürlich extrem pock, wenn das mal funktionieren würde.
Weil Flutter hat den richtigen GUI-Ansatz.
Ich finde Xamarin suckt aus dem einfachen Grund,
weil die halt, also erstens, weil sie es extrem übertreiben,
was ihre XAML-Geschichte angeht.
Da besteht ja im Endeffekt das Ding aus 90% XML und 10% Logik.
Aber was mir bei Xamarin auch nicht gefällt,
ist, dass die den gemeinsamen kleinen GUI-Nenner von allen Betriebssystemen nehmen.
Also sprich alle Betriebssysteme, die du unterstützen, nehmen sie die Native Controls.
Linux, ich glaube es gibt sogar mittlerweile eine Alpha- oder Beta-Variante für Linux, die GTK verwendet.
Das Problem, was du damit hast, ist, wenn du deine Controls,
da habe ich mich schon oft drüber ausgelassen,
wenn du deine Controls nicht selber malst als GUI-Framework,
bist du immer davon abhängig, dass du quasi den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner
aller Plattformen, die du supportest, nimmst.
Und wenn ein Button dann eben bei der einen Plattform kein Bild kann,
kann halt dein Button nirgendwo ein Bild.
Ich finde, alle ordentlichen GUI-Frameworks malen ihre GUI-Elemente selber
und im besten Fall natürlich mit irgendeiner Low-Level-Technik.
Also sprich unter Windows werden die Dinger da mit DirectX gemalt oder mit Direct2D
und unter allen anderen Plattformen werden sie entweder mit OpenGL oder irgendwas anderem gemalt.
Das ist, finde ich, der beste Ansatz.
Qt macht das auch so.
Qt.
Da wollten wir übrigens auch mal eine...
Test-App basteln.
Nein, bei nichts.
Dems fällt mir gerade so ein.
So, also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Wobei, kein Schimmer.
Student, nein.
Database-Administrator.
Datenbank ist so echt, ist echt so ein Thema, wo ich sagen muss,
da könnte ich auch noch sehr viel, sehr viel lernen.
Ich meine, ich kriege so basic Sachen hin.
Ich kriege mal einen Join hin.
Ich kann mal irgendwie ein bisschen SQL zusammen basteln.
Ich kann ein paar Subselects machen oder sowas.
Aber wirklich, wo soll ich planen von Datenbanken, habe ich nicht.
Da gehört ja auch einiges an Theorie dahinter, wie man das am besten aufbaut.
Weil mal so Popel-Anwendungen, die wir hier im Stream machen, ist das ja nicht weiter wild.
Aber bei ordentlichen Anwendungen kommt es natürlich darauf an, dass die Datenbank auch dementsprechend durchdacht ist.
So, Designer.
Also, was Design angeht, bin ich...
Also, was Grafiken und so angeht, bin ich nicht so richtig gut.
Ich finde, ich kann ganz gut einschätzen, was farblich...
...zusammenpasst, halbwegs.
Aber, ähm...
Irgendwelche Sachen zeichnen oder, oder, oder...
...designen.
Ich meine, ihr müsst euch...
Guck mal, wenn ihr meine Designerskills sehen wollt, müsst ihr euch nur die Thumbnails von meinem YouTube-Channel angucken.
Da wisst ihr schon Bescheid, ne?
Wenn ihr euch die Thumbnails von meinem YouTube-Channel anguckt, da wisst ihr schon Bescheid.
Was ich zum Thema Design, äh...
...sage, ja?
Ich meine, für YouTube-Verhältnisse sind die gar nicht übel, die Thumbnails, ja?
Aber...
Ich meine, so die hohe Kunst ist es jetzt nicht, ja?
Die hohe Kunst ist es jetzt echt nicht.
Vor allem das da, oder? Fuck.
Naja.
So, also, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
DevOps-Specialist, ja.
Das ist das, womit ich gerade mein Geld verdiene.
Ähm...
Embedded Applications.
Bis auf ein bisschen ESP32, Arduino...
Keine Ahnung.
Mir fällt immer wieder auf, wenn ich mir solche Listen ausgucke, dass ich mich relativ...
...breit eigentlich auskenne.
Ähm...
Aber halt wenig, wirklich richtig gut.
Alter, mach vor, ich setz' das mal meine...
...meine Thumbnails nicht, sonst gibt's das Abo.
Data Scientist oder Machine Learning Specialist.
Okay.
Uh, äh...
Qualitätssicherung.
Ja, das...
Also die Verteilung kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen.
United States...
White...
Oh, oh.
Nach Männlein und Weiblein.
Oh, das darf man ja so auch gar nicht...
...nicht mehr sagen.
Oh je.
Nach Gender...
...geordnet.
Hä?
Die Statistik versteh ich nicht.
Wo seh ich jetzt, was was ist?
Kann man das hier irgendwie anklicken?
Kann man die irgendwie umschalten zwischen...
...zwischen Frauen und Männern?
Versteht das jemand?
Gewichtet und nicht sortiert.
Ja, und was...
Was bedeutet gewichtet in dem Fall?
Okay, das...
Ich check das...
Die Statistik kapier ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Da bin ich...
...hab ich nicht...
...big brain genug heute.
Gewichtet, also hat eine Frau mehr Prozentpunkte als ein Mann.
Ach so, meinst du, ist das so verteilt?
Also sprich quasi, dass...
...das, keine Ahnung...
...wenn...
...hundert Männer und eine Frau abgestimmt haben...
...und die hätten dann gesagt, ähm...
...hätten sich hier drauf verteilt...
...dass dann quasi das, wo die eine Frau abgestimmt hat, quasi...
...weiter, also mehr...
...Punkte quasi kriegt.
Okay.
Was auch immer einem die Statistik jetzt sagen soll.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist...
...hätte jetzt eigentlich eher gedacht, dass es im Frontend...
...im Frontend und im Designbereich mehr Mädels gibt.
Sein?
Ja doch, tatsächlich, im Designbereich gibt es mehr Mädels.
Ähm...
Ansonsten ist die Statistik eigentlich ziemlich irrelevant, oder?
Finde ich nicht schön gemacht.
Ähm...
Konnte ich muting to open source software?
Interessant.
Also ich finde es interessant, dass so viele...
...immer noch...
...gar nichts damit am Hut haben.
Sodass ich wahnsinnig viel...
...kontributen würde.
Also ich befinde mich auch hier drinnen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist.
Ich befinde mich hier drinnen.
Nicht oft.
Aber ab und zu.
Ähm...
Coding as a hobby.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Sonst würde ich ja hier keinen Stream machen.
Ja, ich programmiere auch außerhalb von der Arbeit.
Wobei ich ja wie gesagt...
...der Arbeit nicht mal hauptsächlich programmiere.
Deswegen finde ich das hier gerade gut, dass wir das im Stream machen können.
Ready Germany, das ist eigentlich total einfach.
Wenn du Software benutzt, die open source ist, die ein GitHub-Projekt hat...
...und die irgendwas auf den Keks geht...
...oder du auch nur Verbesserungsvorschläge hast...
...oder vielleicht sogar auch nur die API-Doku ein bisschen schöner schreiben willst...
...kannst du mitmachen.
Die meisten freuen sich drüber.
Und oftmals ist es so, dass gerade...
...so die einfachen Dinger...
...auch, ähm...
...erwähnt werden auf der Seite.
Weil man damit hofft, man kriegt die Leute dazu einzusteigen.
Also beispielsweise Linux-Kernel macht das so...
...die sagen oder die ermutigen quasi Leute dazu...
...Dokumentationsfixes einzureichen und sowas.
Ja, haha.
Jetzt eben habe ich es gerade übertrieben mit kopieren, oder?
Ja.
Weil die halt hoffen, dass die Leute damit den Einstieg finden.
So wirklich Code-Kontributen für den Linux-Kernel an sich...
...das könnten eh nur die wenigsten.
Aber ich meine...
...alles ist besser als nix.
Ja, hier auch auf jeden Fall.
Macht auch keinen großen Unterschied.
Macht auch weltweit keinen großen Unterschied.
Hier ist Science Learning...
...äh...
...das heißt, die Jahre seit man Programmieren gelernt hat.
Boah!
Alter!
Hahaha!
50 Jahre, nä!
Ähm...
Wie lange ist denn das her?
2000...
...wann...
...wann kam denn...
...wann kam denn .NET...
...kamen zwei .NET Framework 2 raus?
Hier, 2002.
Also ein bisschen davor habe ich angefangen schon rumzubasteln.
Also sagen wir mal 2001.
Also 15, 15 Jahre...
...15 bis 19 Jahre.
Oh...
...da...
...würde ich mich wiederfinden hier.
Da sind noch Lochkarten-Programmierer dabei.
Also hier unten auf jeden Fall!
Hahaha!
50 Jahre, the fuck!
Die haben noch Kabel zwischen unterschiedlichen...
...Registern...
...geschleppt.
Und, und, äh...
...damals hat man ja Kabel nicht gelötet, damals hat man Kabel ja gedreht um die Kontakte.
Wenn du wieder nach der Schule wirst...
...würdest du wieder Programmierer werden oder was anderes?
Ich würde das schon wieder machen.
Ich habe, wie gesagt ich habe, ich habe ja nicht Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt.
Ich habe nicht Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt, ja.
Ich habe System-Integration gelernt damals.
Und ich habe auch in dem Bereich eine Weile geschafft.
Aber mittlerweile bin ich halt im DevOps-Bereich gelandet.
Aber ich programmiere halt auch schon seit, ja, 15 bis 19 Jahren.
So.
Hier ist Coding Professionnali.
Englisch Pro wieder angesagt.
ja das ist schwierig so richtig also ich bin kein haupt hauptberuflicher
programmierer also ich meine ich programmier auf der arbeit auch was aber
hauptsächlich lese ich den code von anderen leuten was ja nicht wirklich
programmieren ist allerdings jetzt seit ich twitch partner bin ist natürlich
noch viel besser weil wenn ich jetzt auf twitch programmier ist das ja auch
professionell programmieren weil professionell heißt ja eigentlich nur
dass man geld für kriegt man muss ja auch nicht gut sein
es wird ja oftmals verwechselt ja nur weil irgendjemand sagt er ist er ist er
ist professionell heißt es nicht dass der gut ist das heißt nur dann für die
geld mit ich würde mal sagen also wenn man wenn man mal sagen damit rechnet so
den aktuellen job wo ich jetzt bin da bin ich seit 2000 2000
also dann würde ich sagen hier
da was hört sich schon als eine der vz ist zurzeit ja auch ein eines der
buzzwords schlechthin wobei schon wieder ab abflacht heute musste cloud architect
sein um hip zu sein muss doch wissen wie du
dein kubernetes richtig schön scale und wie du fast verwendet kein mensch weiß
was fast heißt eigentlich angesagt wer auch immer sich das ausgedacht hat dass
die übel kaputt an
Serverless, Microservice, natürlich.
Natürlich.
Serverless, Microservice, Architekt.
Huge, Big Brain.
Das kannst du nicht einfach mit normalem Hirn machen.
Also da brauchst du schon ein extra großes Hirn.
Okay, weiter, mal gucken.
Was ich hier aber eigentlich ganz interessant finde, ist,
dass es anscheinend wenige Leute gibt, die den Kram lange durchhalten.
Gut, ich meine so richtig, ich meine, guck mal,
2000 rum gab es auch schon viele Programmierer.
Ich glaube, auf Dauer macht das kaum einer lange.
Guck mal, es haben weniger, es haben 20% das nur in den letzten 5 Jahren gelernt
und Arbeiten tun 41%.
Das heißt, es haben viele Leute vorher gelernt und dann erst später zum Beruf gemacht.
Aber ich kann es verstehen, wenn man wirklich den ganzen Tag programmieren muss,
kann es schon sein, dass man danach eine Weile geht.
Wenn man keinen Bock mehr drauf hat.
Vor allem wahrscheinlich in der Gaming-Industrie.
Entwickler mit, oh, Visual Basic.
Nein, das ist nicht mal Visual Basic, das ist VBA.
Das ist Visual Basic for Applications oder wie der Kram heißt.
Wonka Shake.
Visual Basic.
F-Sharp, okay.
Dachte nicht, dass da so viele lange dabei sind.
Closure, okay.
Kotlin haben die wenigsten Erfahrungen, aber gut, das gibt es ja nicht so lang.
PHP auch die wenigsten Erfahrungen, aber PHP hat ganz lange Leute schon, Python auch.
Gut, Python ist ja auch erst die letzten 10 Jahre so richtig,
die letzten 5 Jahre so richtig krass hip geworden.
Obwohl es das auch schon ewig lange gibt.
Das ist auch schon 20 Jahre oder so.
Oder länger.
Okay, und jetzt was sie sind, was die Leute gelernt haben.
Vice President, ja, okay.
Ach so, mit den unterschiedlichen Erfahrungen.
Ja gut, als Senior Executive Vice President, da programmierst du ja nicht mehr selbst.
Da hast du Programmiererfahrung und dann machst du was anderes.
Da bin ich.
Da passe ich doch eigentlich ganz gut rein mit allem, was bisher...
Da deckt sich ziemlich gut mit meinen Erfahrungen auch so.
Game or Graphics.
Das sind so die durchschnittlichen Jahre, die man Erfahrung hat.
Ja gut, den Bereich gibt es ja noch gar nicht so lange.
Hast du einen Microsoft-DevOps-Zertifikat?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es einen Microsoft-DevOps-Zertifikat gibt.
Die erste Zeile Code.
Boah.
Keine Ahnung.
Wann kommen Meme-Modes, wenn ich welche gemacht habe?
Das erste, was es gibt, ist auf jeden Fall Wupp-S.
Wupp-S.
Das erste.
Wupps.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr.
Jünger als 30.
Na auf jeden Fall.
Jünger als 20.
Die erste Zeile Code.
Boah.
Die erste Zeile Code wird, glaube ich, in der Schule irgendwas sein.
Keine Ahnung.
Echt keinen, keinen flassen Schimmer.
Wahrscheinlich so in dem Dreh hier oder so.
Aber echt keine Ahnung.
Ich finde es interessant, dass es Leute gibt, die unter 10 schon angefangen haben.
Nice.
Also nicht, dass die unbedingt dabei geblieben sind.
Wie ich sehe, hast du dir Darkrider angeschaut.
Ja, aber auch nur, weil das jemand empfohlen hat im Stream vorhin.
Wie viel Geld bleibt man vom Sub eigentlich über?
Ich glaube 50-50.
Ich habe es mir jetzt nicht durchgelesen, aber...
Weil im Vorfeld immer wieder, gingen ja immer wieder die, auch quasi die Gerüchte um, dass man so als 0815-Witch-Partner 50-50 kriegt.
Ich habe es nicht durchgelesen.
Ich habe es mir nicht durchgelesen.
Ich glaube 50-50.
Also die...
Hälfte.
Also das heißt, ich müsste jetzt...
Subs habe ich jetzt.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Subscriber.
History sind jetzt 131.
131 mal 2,5.
Easy Money.
327 Euro.
Pock.
Da kann man doch schon mal was mit anfangen.
Und ich wollte gar nicht, ne?
Ihr habt mich ja dazu gedrängt, Partner zu werden.
Ich habe ja schon zwei Jahre gestreamt, ohne Partner zu sein.
Na, Steuern muss ich gar nicht so viele bezahlen, weil ich verdiene so wenig mit YouTube und Zeug in letzter Zeit.
Aber ich habe noch viele Sachen, die abgeschrieben werden gerade.
Weil ich die mal gekauft habe und auch neue Sachen, die ich kaufe, halt auch für die...
Letztendlich diese Tätigkeit hier oder auch für YouTube.
Ähm.
Oder generell.
Generell für Sachen, die halt irgendwas mit der Firma zu tun haben.
Kann ich auch alle abrechnen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Das heißt, die letzten Jahre habe ich immer Steuern wiedergekriegt.
Education.
How many developers are students?
Nope.
Weder jetzt noch früher.
Ich kenne mich mit dem Ami-Schulsystem nicht aus.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich da drin stecke.
Also ich habe keinen Doktor.
Ich habe keinen Professionist.
Ich habe keinen Master's Degree.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Ich habe keinen Bachelor's Degree.
Ich habe keinen, was auch immer, ein Associate Degree ist.
Ich habe keinen Without Degree.
Primary School ist Grundschule, oder?
Secondary School ist was?
Realschule?
Gymnasium?
Keine Ahnung.
Da bin ich nicht drin.
Ich habe ganz normale Schule gemacht und dann habe ich eine Ausbildung gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, wo das hier dazuzählt.
Nochmal Easy-Doktortitel nehmen war, ja.
Äh, passt irgendwie nicht.
Hast du mal eine Weiterbildung gemacht?
Ich habe ein paar Sachen, also ich habe ein paar, äh, Schulungen mal mitgemacht.
Aber die meisten Schulungen gehen mir ehrlich gesagt richtig auf den Keks.
Ähm, die einzige Schulung, die wirklich ganz gut war, die ich gemacht habe, war IPv6.
Das hat auch jemand gemacht, der sich auskennt.
Das fand ich ganz interessant.
Die anderen Schulungen sind alle zum größten Teil echt langweilig gewesen.
Am schlimmsten fand ich immer Schulungen, wo es nicht um irgendwelche Technik geht, sondern um irgendwelche, wie verbessere ich meine Softskills oder sowas.
Da gehe ich nicht mehr hin.
Also, solche Schulungen gehe ich nicht mehr.
Ähm, Softskills, ne.
Ne, weil die Schulungen sind so unglaublich nervig, ja.
Ja.
Das kommt aber auch.
Glaube ich, ab einem gewissen Alter, ab einem gewissen Alter ist man nicht mehr belehrbar so richtig.
Also, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt ja seit ein paar Tagen 35.
Und, ähm, irgendwie, ich lasse mir auch nichts mehr irgendwie erzählen.
Also, ich will mir auch irgendwie nichts mehr erzählen lassen, so.
Es ist leicht, vielleicht ist das bescheuert, ja.
Und ich weiß selbst, dass ich, ähm, in manchen Bereichen nicht der soziale, sag mal, äh, ups.
Nicht in manchen Bereichen selbst, äh, dass ich da sozial nicht der Beste bin, ne.
Wie gesagt, ich, äh, mag Leute, also, ich mag andere Menschen in der Regel halt nicht, ne.
Habe ich ja schon öfters gesagt.
Es sei denn, ich mag sie.
Aber defaultmäßig mag ich sie eigentlich, äh, erstmal nicht.
Und, hä, hä, hä.
Außer natürlich mein Chat.
Ähm.
Wobei, es stimmt so nicht.
Also, in der Regel, in der Regel bin ich eigentlich neutral bei neuen Leuten.
Aber sobald die mir auf den Sack gehen, und das geht halt relativ schnell, mag ich sie nicht mehr.
Naja.
Never sub, never donate, so ist richtig.
Ähm, habe ich eigentlich paar Fragen, ich glaube, ich habe ein paar Fragen übersehen, kann das sein?
Uiuiui, oh, so viel Zeug.
Nice, what's up, bitch?
Hab ich fünf Minuten vorm Stream extra nochmal eingerichtet.
Hat der mCore gestern mal kurz resized die Bilder?
Hast du Code zum Linux-Candle schon mal contributed?
Nein.
Ist Gaming ein Haifischbecken, habe ich mal gehört.
Ich kann es dir aus erster Hand nicht sagen, aber alles, was ich höre, äh, ist es für'n Arsch.
Ich kenne jemanden, der hat bei Crytek gearbeitet, der sagt auch, es ist für'n Arsch.
Mein Crytek ist in Frankfurt bei uns um die Ecke.
Dann kommen Emotes, hatten wir schon.
Bald ist fertig, sobald mir was eingefallen ist.
Ja, auch schon.
Das stimmt.
So, äh, mal weitergucken.
Undergrade Major, was?
Ah, nee, Undergraduate Major.
Ach, das überspringen wir.
Aber ich hab, ich hab nicht.
Ich kenne mich mit dem Ami-Bildungssystem nicht aus, ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Ach, das ist, wenn du an der Universität studiert hast, in was, in was du studiert hast.
Einfach MonkaSmoke.
Ich kann MonkaSmoke nicht als Emote einrichten, weil ich...
Als Prefix muss ich WUP verwenden, ich könnte höchstens WUP-Smoke nehmen.
WUP-Smoke.
WUP-S, könnte man auch machen.
Weiß gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, wie, wie das klein aussieht, das Bild.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wie das in Emote-Größe überhaupt ausschaut.
Ob man den Smoke überhaupt erkennt in Emote-Größe.
Was Crytek jetzt eigentlich macht, ist eine gute Frage.
Die machen so ein komisches Battle Royale, Western, Western Battle Royale Game.
Die basteln an ihrer Cry-Engine rum.
Was macht Crytek? Gute Frage, keine Ahnung.
Showdown, ja.
New Language Framework without Formal Course.
Klar, das hat jeder.
Also, es gibt keinen guten Programmierer oder generell, ich erweitere das mal auf, es gibt keinen, keiner, der im technischen Bereich gut ist, der nicht mal allein eine neue Sprache, neues Framework oder neue Sachen gelernt hat.
Leute, die immer, die Leute, die da sitzen und so lang sagen...
Ich kann es nicht, bis ich eine Schulung bekommen habe, sind in der Regel die übelsten Ober-Kack-Noobs, weil die sich auch absolut nicht dafür interessieren.
Äh, Cheat, ich muss nicht WUP nehmen, aber ich habe WUP jetzt mal als Prefix genommen, weil es irgendwie ganz gut zum Channel passt.
Max war besetzt, Max und M4X war besetzt, da habe ich jetzt einfach mal WUP genommen, weil WUP ist schön, mit WUP kann man schön kombinieren, WUP, mein WUP-S kann man sich auch gut merken.
Der Eng-Online-Kurs hat auch schon jeder mal gemacht.
für einen Pro für die Hälfte oder für weniger als die Hälfte und ein gutes Mikrofon dazukaufen.
Hallo Flo96.
Ja, das ist mein Video zum Thema Gaming-Headsets, das kenne ich noch.
Und es widerspricht sich ja auch überhaupt nicht.
Lohnt sich ja auch nicht, 250 Euro auszugeben.
Weil wir viel einfacher haben.
Ah, jetzt haben wir, das ist die Aufteilung von Programmierern oder generell von Leuten im technischen Bereich nach Herkunft.
Okay, weiß oder europäische Abstammung, 70%.
Das hätte ich jetzt auch nicht anders gerechnet.
Ja, einfach mal von aus, dass in vielen Ländern, wo halt der überwiegende Teil der Leute eben nicht weiß ist,
dass es da nicht so viele Programmier-Jobs gibt.
Oder dass die beim Stack-Overflow-Survey nicht mitmachen, weil in Asien gibt es definitiv auch viele Programmierer.
Oh, Gender.
Jetzt darf ich nichts Falsches sagen.
Äh, jetzt haben 91% Männer mitgemacht, 8% Frauen mitgemacht und 1,2% Non-Binary, was in allen Bereichen ziemlich ähnlich ist.
Developer-Roles in Gender, oh yeah.
Death of a Specialist, Moment, was?
Number of Developers?
Relative Participation, Moment.
Heißt das, dass es in meinem Bereich besonders viele Mädels gibt oder besonders wenige?
Was heißt das jetzt?
Bedeutet das, dass es in meinem Bereich besonders viele oder besonders wenige gibt?
Bei mir sind viele Männer.
Ja, das stimmt, das kann ich unterstreichen.
Ich habe es ja letztens im Stream gesagt, dass wir nur zwei Mädels haben.
Oh nee, das stimmt nicht.
Wir haben schon mehr Mädels, aber bei uns im Bereich gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Mädels.
Und wo wir viele haben, ist iOS, App-Entwicklung und App-Design.
Da haben wir viele.
Mehr als 25 Mal so viele als Frauen.
Ja, wie gesagt, bei uns im Bereich gibt es auch im Prinzip, da gibt es wirklich sehr wenige Mädels.
Ja, das stimmt.
Experience.
Warum kriegen Frauen Sternchen und Männer nicht?
Muss man, muss man gleich hier, muss ich gleich mal an den Diskriminierungsabgeordneten hier von Stack Overflow schreiben.
Das geht ja nicht, Anzeige raus, direkt.
Mocker Sexism, ja.
Aber die Verteilung ist, ja okay, das wundert mich jetzt nicht.
Dass, sag mal so, dass Mädels, dass es mehr Mädels in dem Beruf gibt.
Dass...
Ist ja auch, das hat ja auch erst die letzten, sagen wir mal, zehn Jahre wirklich deutlich zugenommen.
Davor hattest du ja quasi gar keine Mädels.
Und mittlerweile hast du doch vereinzelt auch mal Mädels.
Ja, so im Durchschnitt, sagen wir mal so, im Durchschnitt 15 bis 20 Mal so viele Männer auf Frauen.
Bei uns in der Technik, da bei uns in der Technikecke, wo ich arbeite, also nehmen wir mal alles zusammen, was da mit Technik zu tun hat.
Das spiegelt sich ungefähr wieder, ja.
Also würde ich sagen, 5 bis 20.
20 bis 15 Mal mehr, wenn du als Frau in das kommt, ungefähr hin.
Dafür ist es halt in anderen Bereichen genau umgedreht.
Wenn du in der Personalabteilung guckst, weiß ich gar nicht, ob da überhaupt ein Mann arbeitet bei uns.
Bei App Design und iOS sind auch sehr viele Mädels.
Haben wir noch viele Mädels?
Marketing.
Marketing und Bullshit Bingo ist, da hat auch viele Mädels bei uns.
Halt auch weniger.
Weniger Typen.
Kantine und, ja, Kantine ist eigentlich, würde ich sagen, ziemlich ausgeglichen.
Ja, Flo 96.
Also ohne Mist so.
Wenn man, wenn man, äh, den Job will, wo man viele Mädels um sich hat, musst du in die Personalabteilung oder iOS-Entwickler werden.
Zumindest kann ich das bei uns so beobachten.
Was ist denn Bullshit Bingo?
Sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Haben wir noch von der letzten E3.
EA Bullshit Bingo.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Äh, Orientierung.
Sexuelle Orientierung.
Ausrichtung.
Und die meisten sind, wer hätte das gedacht, einfach nur ganz normal.
Ähm, 5,5 sind bi und schwul und lesbisch sind 2,7.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sich das wahrscheinlich ungefähr decken wird mit den normalen Bevölkerungszahlen auch.
Ich glaube, ich glaube nicht, dass es im Bereich, im Technikbereich jetzt so viel.
Mehr ist.
Ich glaube, das ist überall recht ähnlich, oder?
Ey, 93% ist normal.
Normal ist das, was die Mehrheit ist.
Das heißt nicht, dass normal besser, schlechter oder sonst was ist.
Normal ist einfach nur, was die Mehrheit ist.
Erstmal gleich triggert hier im Chat, äh.
Alle, ich weiß, dass mein Chat fake triggert ist.
Aber, heute, heutzutage musst du ja echt übelst krass aufpassen bei sowas, ne.
Wo sind die Weeps in der Statistik?
Stimmt.
Und, das geht ja gar nicht.
Wo sind, wo sind, wo sind sie?
Die müssen da auch rein.
Da hast du dann, da bräuchte es ja zumindest noch was für.
Ja, das geht ja so nicht.
Wen hat ein Status?
Ähm, haben eine Stimmungs- und Emotionsstörung?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Also, es wurde nie diagnostiziert.
Dass ich sie nicht mehr alle hab, ist mir auch klar.
Aber, ich glaube nicht, dass das, ähm, krankhaft, krankhaft, äh, gestört ist.
Ähm, wie gesagt, festgestellt wurde nix.
Autismus hab ich auch nicht.
Konzentrationsstörung hab ich, aber auch, aber auch nicht, äh, nicht diagnostiziert, ja.
Äh, ich hab da nix.
Prime Sub, Pog.
Und zwar, haben wir da einen Shing, Shingi Kuro?
Shingi Kuro?
Hoffe, das war jetzt nicht komplett, ähm, fail.
Ähm, danke.
Danke.
Danke schön, Twitch Prime.
Pog.
Ah, scheiß.
Oh, ich glaub, wir haben ein neues Emote freigeschaltet.
Ich glaub, wir haben ein neues Emote freigeschaltet.
Also, wo ich keine Emotes habe, aber ich glaub, ich hab jetzt einen neuen Emote-Slot bekommen gerade.
Jetzt hab ich schon, jetzt hab ich elf Emotes.
Also, null von elf Emotes.
Vorher hatte ich nur null von zehn Emotes.
Aber was geht eigentlich mit der Musik da im Hintergrund ab?
Ist ja schrecklich.
So.
Ähm, huch.
Hat sich das jetzt reload?
Hat sich das jetzt reloadet irgendwie?
Age.
Oh, ich bin schon zu alt.
Guck mal.
Vor, vor fünf Tagen war ich noch hier.
Hab ich noch hier dazugehört.
Jetzt gehöre ich dazu.
Drip.
Leben vorbei, ja.
Danke schön, Tobi.
Durchschnittliches Alter.
Deutschland.
30.
Eieieiei.
Da bin ich ja schon voll drüber.
Nochmal, die Deutschen sind Programmier-Noobs.
Die Australier, die kennen sich aus.
Und wie fühlten sich 35 Jahre an, also im Vergleich zu 34, ey, Ewigkeit, ne?
Ja, natürlich ist das überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Indien, 25.
Nee.
Indien, 7,1.
Na gut, das ist der Microsoft Support.
Mein Name ist Peter.
Warum hört sich Peter indisch an?
Man weiß es nicht.
Das ist doch der Typ hier, wartet mal.
Kennt ihr das?
Wo ist das denn?
Scam?
Das da?
Microsoft Sicherheits-Alarm-Fehler.
Ich glaub, das da, komm, das muss man sich mal angucken.
Das war, das war lustig.
Mein Name ist Peter.
Ich glaub, das ist der, aber wo ist die, wo ist die Musik?
Microsoft Sicherheits-Alarm-Fehler Nummer DW6.
Was hat denn der Dude für ein Mikrofon?
Äh, G-Data.
Was wäre denn sowas denn?
VD36.
Ihr Computer hat uns alarmiert, dass er mit schädlichen Trojanern infiziert wurde.
Diese Viren schicken ihre Kreditkartendaten, Facebook-Logins sowie persönliche und private Daten...
Was hat der Typ, was hat, was ist das für ein Mikrofon?
Hat er das irgendwie unterm Schreibtisch hängen und sich draufgesetzt, oder?
...über Remote-IP-Adressen an Hacker weiter.
Max erwartet Studio-Qualität-Mikros von Scammern.
Das ist nicht der Scammer.
Das ist der Scammer, der den Scammer scammt.
Mit ordentlichem Aufnahme-Equipment.
Egal.
So, wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
20 Minuten.
Oh nein.
Und weitere Schäden an unserem Netzwerk verhindert werden.
Außerdem werden wir eine Kopie dieses Berichts an die Netzsicherheit schicken, um weitere Schritte einzuleiten.
Warum hört es sich auch immer an?
Warum hört es sich alle so gleich an?
Es geht jetzt überhaupt nicht um Inder-Klischee oder so, aber die hören sich alle so an.
Die ganzen Scammer hören sich so an.
R wie Rudolf.
Ist die Lautstärke okay vom Scammer?
Stabber R. R wie Rudolf.
Internet Explorer, erstmal aufmachen.
Jawohl, habe ich.
Jetzt bin ich hier auf fastsupport.com.
Verbindung für Support aufbauen.
Genau, schreiben Sie zuerst Ihren Namen.
Und schließen.
Ja, drei Moment.
Ich mein…
Hier ist druckbank-nach props bites sind zu laut.
Ja
...Neun.
Ich main, das ist übils kompliziert.
Wenn die vielleicht versucht hätten meine Oma zu scammen.
Hätte der Scam, oder sowas schonmal nicht funktioniert, weil die noch nicht in der Lageмотря sowas zu befolgen gewesen.
Das ist viel zu kompliziert.
Missbrauch melden.
Wahrscheinlich, weil fastsupport.com DER Mполg fool.
ist wirklich ausgerüstet.
von so vielen seriösen Leuten verw grinderis-
leuten verwendet wird 6 3 96 96 ja habe ich den scheiß auch noch download schon ewig her dass
das gekonnt habe es wird immer seriöser es wird immer seriöser jetzt möchten sie go to assist
ob eine exe downloaden ja unbedingt ja wohl ausführen um goto es ist auch immer auf ja
klicken ok goto assist wird das ist bis jetzt noch eine ganz normale goto assist
wahrscheinlich ganz ehrlich ich kenne dieses programm nicht
kann sein dass das voll das ist vollkommen legit es bricht nichts dagegen die wollen
einfach remote zugang haben wahrscheinlich wäre es einfacher mit irgendeinem mit irgendeinem
fertigen wie heißt das teamviewer oder sowas aber keine ahnung bis jetzt ist ja noch halbwegs normal
klicken ja wunderbar jetzt kommt es gleich
am besten also die die gibt es die gibt ihnen jetzt gleich einen anderen support
mitarbeiter weiter und da müsst ihr mal drauf hören wie der sich meldet
richtig da war irgendwie weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau wie die meldung hieß ich hatte mir die
telefonnummer jetzt aufgeschrieben und dann versucht selber irgendwie da ein bisschen was
zu machen
der hochqualifizierte techniker
danke sehr jetzt passt mal auf wie der sich meldet
ich bin noch da ja
das erwischt mich jedes mal
der name ist peter ist klar natürlich wie soll er sonst heißen da ist natürlich später
wir gucken das jetzt noch fertig geht ja geht ja nur noch 17 minuten 15 minuten
wunderbar
richtig das war gestern oder vorgestern vorgestern war es tatsächlich abends irgendwann
ok
ich kann eigentlich in ihrem computer weiter arbeiten und diese probleme bereinigen
jawohl was macht peter da lassen sie mir scheinbar den computer ganz position vor
die ok ja ja ja ja ja ok so warten sie jetzt macht er macht er in der konsol oder so oft da
ja ich war ich warte ich warte bis sie fertig sind
der findet noch nicht mal was er sucht ist der ist nicht der ist gar nicht einmal unfähiger scammer
jetzt zeig mal ja
weiß ich leider nicht also ich war auch ganz überrascht
ja das mohn kann ja ganz gut richtig bei mir alles in sich ist also aber das ist alles perfekt in meinem computer ist nicht sichtbar nicht weiß ich leider nicht also ich war auch ganz überrascht
Und weiter?
Okay, jetzt sagt er nichts mehr.
Da brauchst du schon
Big Braille, um auf so eine Idee zu kommen.
So viele Hackversuche.
Irgendein komisches .NET-Programm ist abgekackt.
Der hat irgendwie Strom
eingeschaltet.
Der Timo
Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Es gibt, Leute,
es gibt tausende
solcher Inder-Scam-Videos.
Okay, ja, ich sehe es.
Ja, logisch.
Ja, sehe ich.
Ist doch ganz klar, oder?
Erstmal TCP,
Netznet.
Genau, Netznet.
So schlecht.
Ja.
Das ist die Adresse
von meinem Computer?
Richtig.
Das ist so unglaublich.
Ich habe einen Fail.
Ich habe eine Erklärung.
Die ist nicht nur dumm,
die ist auf so vielen Ebenen
Fail, ey.
Okay, also die Leute haben jetzt
alle Zugriff auf meinen Rechner?
Natürlich.
Was sonst? Natürlich.
So klar.
Komm, wir gucken mal, wie viele Leute
Zugriff auf meinen Rechner aktuell haben.
Netznet mit Parameter
einfach nur Netznet.
Oh, fuck.
Fuck.
Jetzt bin ich im Arsch.
Warum genau hat sich mein Rechner zu meinem Shield-TV
verbunden?
Warum?
Wahrscheinlich ist es der Chrome.
Wahrscheinlich ist es der Chrome, der Dings, ähm,
Chromecast scannt oder so.
Die krassen Hacks, oh, hier, guckt euch das mal an.
Kann man nicht sagen, minus N, dass er keinen Name-Locker
macht, doch hier. Guck mal hier.
So viele Hacker.
Fuck.
Jetzt vorbei.
Wir müssen das Ganze wieder einhacken.
Weil Sie können hier die Statue sehen.
Hier hergestellt.
Oh.
Moment, da haben wir jetzt gar nicht danach geguckt.
Wir haben gar nicht geguckt, ob es hergestellt war.
Gut, bei mir steht da wahrscheinlich Established da, aber.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Alles, alles voller Hacker.
Vor allem, ich, ich hacke mich ja auch 20 Mal selber hier oben.
Darf man nicht vergessen, ne?
Also ich, ich, ich hacke mich erst ein paar Mal selber.
Und dann werde ich von meiner VM gehackt.
Und dann hackt mich Amazon.
Gipp.
...gestellt.
So diese Personen können jederzeit in Ihrem Computer reinkommen,
irgendwas, ja.
Aha, okay.
So wir müssen diese alle,
wir müssen diese alle...
Mhm, okay.
Ganz, ganz weg.
...sagt man ja.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Okay, okay.
Ja, gerne.
Warten Sie bitte, ja.
Okay.
Das werde ich auch hier einmal zeigen.
Hä?
Ich werde hier einen Scanner in Ihrem Computer durchführen lassen, okay?
Ja.
Wie Sie sehen können, es gibt auch Copys in Ihrem Computer.
Was?
Coop-Face?
Was ist Coop-Face?
Ist das irgendeine Malware?
Ja, aber Leute, jetzt lernt er mal wenigstens was.
Also wenn ihr keine Ahnung von Netzwerktechnik habt,
guckt euch das Video von mit Peter an.
Wissen Sie, was ist Coop-Face?
Wissen Sie, was ist...
Coop-Face?
Achso, nee, das weiß ich nicht.
Erklären Sie mir mal.
Warten Sie bitte, ja.
Ja.
Coop-Face?
Was ist Coop-Face?
Wissen Sie, was ist Coop-Face?
Achso, nee, das weiß ich nicht.
Erklären Sie mir mal.
Warten Sie bitte, ja.
Ja.
Coop-Face?
Achso, nee, das weiß ich nicht.
Erklären Sie mir mal.
Warten Sie bitte, ja.
Moment.
Coop-Face?
Das war Wikipedia aufgemacht.
Ja.
So dieser Coop-Face ist auch drin in Ihrem Computer,
bitte.
Bitte selber haben Sie das gefunden.
Okay.
Aber da stand jetzt in dem Artikel auch drin,
dass das irgendwie nur bis 2010 war.
Und so lange habe ich den...
Wenn Sie den Rechner haben, wie Sie sehen können,
das ist schon in Ihrem Computer bitte drin.
Ja.
Ja, aber so lange habe ich den Rechner noch nicht.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, aber so lange habe ich den Rechner noch gar nicht.
Hä?
Sehen Sie bitte hier.
Ich habe da vorhin darüber...
Dieser Coop-Face in Ihrem Computer.
So diese aller Probleme...
Klingt logisch.
Was ein Satz, Alter.
Was ein Satz.
Diese Probleme, die in Ihrem...
Diese Probleme, die in Ihrem Computer sind,
sind wie ein Coop-Face.
Äh...
Was?
Sind wie ein Coop-Face.
Okay?
Das habe ich Ihnen gezeigt, was ein Coop-Face ist.
Ja.
Okay.
So dieser Coop-Face ist in Ihrem Computer.
Äh...
Was?
Sind wie ein Coop-Face.
Okay?
Das habe ich Ihnen gezeigt, was ein Coop-Face ist.
Ja.
Okay.
So diese aller Probleme...
Okay?
Ja.
Okay.
So wenn nicht am Apparat sowieso wie im Moment ist,
und nach meiner Arbeit...
Leute!
Spiel nur...
Was...
Was will der denn machen?
Ja.
Okay.
Also wir...
Ich lasse den Rechner jetzt einfach stehen,
und Sie machen die Arbeit.
Ja?
Richtig.
Und in diesem Fall,
um diese Probleme zu bereinigen,
brauche ich hier die gekaufte Programme installieren,
damit ich kann diese Probleme in Ihrem Computer installieren.
Ja.
Okay?
So Sie können sich entscheiden,
wie viele Side-Docker Sie dieser Programme uns so...
Unsere Hilfe...
Ich bin froh, dass uns Peter das jetzt mal richtig erklärt,
wie das...
Wie man das...
Wie man das richtig macht.
So einmalig...
Einmalig diese Probleme zu bereinigen,
oder ein Jahr,
oder zwei Jahre,
oder leben sagen wir...
Moment!
Er hat dann nicht gerade erzählt...
Also...
Er hat mal davon abgesehen...
Ja, wir wissen alle,
es ist Scam.
Aber...
Selbst in der Scammer-Logik,
ergibt es keinen Sinn,
weil...
Also...
Es ergibt keinen Sinn,
weil wenn er doch jetzt Coop-Face entfernt vom Rechner,
warum soll ich ihn dann fünf Jahre bezahlen,
um Coop-Face zu entfernen?
Das versteht wahrscheinlich nur Peter selbst.
Okay, und...
Und...
Oder Lebenslagen.
Wie bezahle ich das dann?
Mache ich dann eine Überweisung,
oder...
Herr, ich erkläre Ihnen,
diese einmalige Reparatur kostet 40.149,
plus die Mehrwertsteuer.
Okay.
Eine einjährige Vertragswerte
hierfür kostet 30.149,
plus die Steuer.
Okay.
Boah, ist das teuer.
Eine einjährige Vertragswerte
hierfür kostet 30.149,
plus die Steuer.
Ja.
Und...
Okay.
So, was kostet die hier,
bitte?
Schnapper.
30.149,
plus Mehrwertsteuer.
Das ist komplett für sechs Jahre.
Okay?
Mhm.
Und die Lebenslagen-Unterschützung
kostet hier 808,
80 Euro,
plus die Steuer.
Umsonst?
Eieiei, umsonst?
Das ist ja fast...
Das ist ja...
No-Brainer, ey.
Okay.
Wie viel Zeit brauchen Sie
dieser Unterschützung?
Damit ich kann,
sie registrieren
und können wir
diese Probleme
nicht auf dem Computer
wegmachen.
Ich sag mal,
ich kann da natürlich
jetzt auch einfach hingehen
und den Rechner einmal selber
neu aufsetzen.
Da ist ja jetzt im Moment
nicht viel drauf.
Das würde ja eigentlich
auch helfen, oder?
Mein Internet ist infiziert.
Fuck.
Aber ich bin ja froh.
Zum Glück,
zum Glück ist nur
mein Internet infiziert.
Stellt euch mal vor,
wo wir hingekommen wären,
wenn das Internet
mit Coopface infiziert wäre.
Okay.
Und wenn ich
einen Virenschutz drauf habe?
Herr, wie gesagt,
ein Virenschutzprogramm
ist noch nicht
in Ihrem Komplex.
Ah ja.
Wie bezahle ich das denn?
Weil eine Kreditkarte
habe ich nicht.
Herr, kein Problem.
Sie können mir
erst einmal
bezahlen.
Oder ein Jahr
lang.
Lebenslange.
Also, wenn,
dann überhaupt nur einmalig.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich weiß ja nicht,
wie wir das dann
mit der Bezahlung machen.
Herr, ich sage leider
nicht,
wie können Sie bitte
das Geld
hier feststellen.
Möglichkeiten.
Sie können das
mit Banküberweisung
machen.
Ja.
Online Banking?
Nein, Online Banking
mache ich gar nicht.
Okay.
Dann lassen wir das.
Und die zweite Möglichkeit
haben wir hier ist,
mit iTunes Karte
das ...
iTunes Karte?
Haha.
Der Microsoft Support
lässt sich per
iTunes Karte bezahlen.
Seems legit.
Wer hat es noch nicht erlebt,
dass ihr den Support
per iTunes Karte
bezahlen müsst?
Was ist der Unterschied davon?
Mit Banküberweisung?
Ja, okay.
Der will,
dass er mit
iTunes Karten bezahlt.
Mit welchen Programmen
arbeiten Sie denn eigentlich?
Herr,
das wissen wir
eigentlich nicht.
Mit welchem Programm
arbeiten Sie denn?
Ich bin der Experte,
aber ich habe
keine Ahnung.
Der Diagnostik-Experte
ist auch ...
Das sind unsere
dritte Stufe Experten,
die in Ihrem ...
Können Sie das Geld
nicht von meinem Konto
abbuchen?
Geht das?
Natürlich,
da kannst du
zurück buchen.
Das ist ja
eine gute Frage.
Wir akzeptieren
diese ...
Kurze Frage,
wie ist das denn,
selbst wenn ich jetzt ...
Wenn ich jetzt sage,
ich möchte das überhaupt
nicht haben,
kostet mich das dann
jetzt trotzdem was?
Sie müssen ...
Sie sind verpflichtet,
weil Sie uns
angerufen haben.
Okay,
aber eigentlich möchte
ich ja gar nicht,
dass da irgendjemand
auf meinem Rechner
irgendwie sich Zugang
verschafft.
Und da kann ich
ja auch einfach
jetzt hingehen
und den Stecker
am Rechner rausziehen.
Oh nein,
das geht auf keinen Fall.
Und ich sage mal,
ich habe einen Freund,
der richtig viel Ahnung
von Computern hat.
Das könnte ich den doch
eigentlich auch machen
lassen, oder?
Natürlich nicht.
Aber was?
Okay,
wenn Sie jetzt sagen,
Sie haben so viel,
also so sehr erfahrene
Mitarbeiter,
was haben die denn
für Zertifizierungen?
Was haben die für
Zertifizierungen?
Zertifiziert von Windows,
krass.
Zertifiziert von Windows
würde ich auch
kämmer werden.
Okay,
also ich glaube,
ich möchte da erstmal
einen Freund
von mir drauf schauen lassen.
Dann würde ich sagen,
wenn das wirklich
nicht klappen sollte,
dann kann ich Sie ja
nochmal anrufen, oder?
Ich würde jetzt erstmal
meinen Freund
das reparieren lassen
und wenn der
das nicht schafft,
dann würde ich mich
nochmal bei Ihnen melden.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Was kommt jetzt?
Da kann ich mich
auch nicht mehr
dran erinnern.
Das ist jetzt
ein anderer Typ.
Alles kaputt.
Verstehen Sie das?
Ja,
ich sage mal,
selbst wenn alles
kaputt geht,
ist nicht schlimm.
So viel ist
auf dem Rechner
nicht drauf.
Den Rechner
kann ich auch
neu aufsetzen.
Verstehen Sie?
Jetzt müssen Sie ihm
überhaupt noch erstmal
erklären,
dass es sogar
wichtig ist,
nicht,
dass er auf die Idee
kommt,
es einfach sein zu lassen.
Verstehen Sie das?
Verstehen Sie?
Haben Sie es
jetzt endlich verstanden?
Das geht kaputt bedeutet,
alle Teile
gehen kaputt.
Das geht kaputt,
das bedeutet,
alle Teile
gehen kaputt.
Endlich mal jemand,
der sich auskennt.
Das geht kaputt.
Sie können das nicht.
Aber ich habe doch
eine Sicherung.
Also da ist
die Sicherung
ist in Ordnung.
Welche Sicherung
Sie haben?
Ich habe alle meine Daten,
die ich auf dem Rechner
G-Data.
Der Typ hat es auch noch
im Hintergrund.
Nee,
hat es nicht im Hintergrund.
da hat es unten
hier eingehört.
Da hat hier G-Data,
da hat er unten
eine Tastleiste
drauf.
Die habe ich gesichert.
Ganz einfach.
Wie machen wir
denn jetzt
an der Stelle weiter?
In Zukunft?
Also ich habe,
ich habe mich jetzt
eigentlich entschieden,
ich möchte da erstmal
einen Freund draufschauen
lassen und wenn dann
die Sachen wirklich
noch alle kaputt sind,
dann würde ich Sie
einfach nochmal anrufen.
Okay.
Ja.
Weil es da stand.
Weil in der Meldung
drin stand,
dass man anrufen soll.
Sie haben diese Meldung.
Das ist richtig.
Und da stand drin,
ich soll anrufen.
Ja.
Ich möchte Ihnen fragen,
warum haben Sie
nur unsere Nummer
bekommen?
Oh,
jetzt kommt.
Ich erkläre.
Sie haben nur unsere
Nummer bekommen.
Okay.
Was zum Teufel?
Was?
Wollten,
will er uns jetzt
sagen jetzt,
jetzt,
er macht es jetzt
kostenlos oder was?
Okay,
aber wenn ich jetzt,
wenn ich jetzt einen Freund
von mir frage,
dann bezahle ich
ja auch nichts.
Ich wünsche Ihnen
einen schönen Tag.
Okay.
Den wünsche ich auch.
Danke sehr.
E-Mail-Verbindung
ist noch an.
Ich hätte es eigentlich
gedacht,
der, der,
der beleidigt
noch ein bisschen.
Guck,
jetzt haben sie
ihren ganzen Shit drauf
gemacht und im Hintergrund
haben sie das Ding
verschlüsselt.
Ja.
Fail.
In der Scam.
Der ist lustig.
Also wir gucken
jetzt nicht an.
Aber der Channel ist,
ist,
ist gut.
Der hat,
der hat ein paar Sachen
drauf.
Da habe ich schon ein paar
Sachen von ihm geguckt.
Er ist,
ist nice.
Ja,
wie gesagt,
wir können uns jetzt nicht
den ganzen Tag indischen
Call-Center-Scam angucken.
Eigentlich wollte ich auch
ein bisschen Broggers machen,
aber,
also,
sag mal so,
wir haben jetzt 19.30 Uhr.
Wir haben jetzt 19.30 Uhr.
Ähm,
eine halbe Stunde können
wir uns noch was angucken.
Da muss ich was futtern.
Wollen wir uns,
wollen wir uns noch,
wollen wir uns noch was angucken?
Wir können uns,
wir gucken uns noch,
komm,
ähm,
gucken wir uns noch an.
Was passt denn?
Scammer vs.
Hannah Montana Linux.
What?
Okay,
das müssen wir mal kurz gucken.
Das müssen,
das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Das klingt so abgedreht.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Das geht wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so lang.
Welchen Operationssystem
benutze ich eigentlich?
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich weiß gar nicht,
wo diese Videos gehen.
Lasst uns in die
Hannah Montana Linux
loggen.
Das ist ein wirklich
sicherer Passwort von
One.
Dieses Operationssystem
basiert auf Ubuntu,
aber es ist
Moment.
Aus.
Off.
Das ist der erste,
den ich kenne,
der allen Ernstes
Hannah Montana Linux
installiert hat.
Hat der eine VM
in der VM?
Der hat eine doppelte
VM.
Der geht ab.
Kratzer Hexer,
er.
Der hat eine doppelte
Windows 10.
Da drin hat er
Windows 7 laufen
und in Windows 7
hat er,
nee,
Moment,
doch.
In Windows 7
hat er seine Hannah Montana
Linux VM laufen.
Sicher ist sicher.
Beim Scam
Inder weiß man nie.
Pretty terrible.
Look at it.
Who's gonna use
this on a regular
basis,
really?
It's just
a resolution.
In fact,
I better put it
in full screen
and it
uncapture
first.
Okay,
there we go,
it resized itself.
But what I've noticed about
this, the taxpayer
doesn't even fit.
Oh no,
I'm a schemer.
Thank you for calling,
this is Brandon,
how may I help you?
Hi Brandon,
there's an issue with my
computer.
Brandon,
is this yours?
What is the issue?
I was getting this pop-up
and my computer's being
really slow.
Okay,
may I have your name
please so I can address
you in a better way?
Yeah,
my name's Terry,
T-E-R-R-Y.
Terry?
Yeah, Terry.
For verification purpose,
4th of March,
1987.
Thank you so much.
Now, Terry,
what I'll be doing right now
is to get a better picture
of what the problem is.
I will get your computer
connected to our technical team
where we'll validate...
Das müsste man
eigentlich mal live,
das müsste man eigentlich
echt mal im Stream
irgendwie machen.
Man müsste sich
eine VM in einer VM machen
und dann beim
inner support anrufen.
... your computer...
Wir nehmen
irgendeine fake
VoIP-Nummer.
... recognize
what the issue is
and help you out, okay?
Right, okay.
And just keep in mind,
like if there is
a serious issue
or the fix of the issue
and everything,
there would be a one-time
and a one-off
charge involved.
So are you okay
with the charge?
Okay, yeah.
What do you see
on your screen right now?
I can see my desktop
at the minute.
Now, with one finger
press the four-flag windows key
and with another finger
press the letter R.
Right, okay.
Type in over there
www dot
support,
S-U-P-P-O-R-T,
support.
Okay, yeah.
Dot me, M-E.
Support dot me, okay.
And now,
do I press enter?
Yeah, click on it
and hit the enter key
and let me know
Okay, and I can see
a support connection
and your six-digit code.
Type down your code
as one eight three.
One eight three?
Nine zero zero.
Okay.
Play and start download.
Now at the bottom
you get...
Can you see that?
I can see that, yeah.
It's saying
run and cancel.
During the course
of trouble shooting
I will request you
to stay in front
of the computer
to understand
the diagonal
and trouble shooting
will be in time.
Right, okay.
And at any point
of time during the session
if you wish to disconnect.
Macht er jetzt
macht er jetzt
die VM auf
und dann Fullscreen
oder was?
Was genau hat er vor?
Check on the red X
and get disconnected.
Now, however,
during the course
of trouble shooting
you would be
the primary controller
and I would be
the secondary controller, okay?
Right, okay.
So you can see
my desktop now, can't you?
Yes, I can see it now.
What is the problem
that you're facing?
It was a pop-up
but I pressed...
I reopened the browser
and I said
don't restore
so it hasn't come back up.
And which browser
this is?
Internet Explorer?
Ja, Internet Explorer.
Eindeutsch.
I'm not sure.
I'm not very good
with computers.
But I don't think
you're not good with computers.
You are pretty good
with computers.
I appreciate it,
but I would have been
fixing it myself
if I was that good.
What's this web history for?
Check and see
all the websites
where this comes from.
Ah, okay.
You need to go
to your history.
I don't know where that is.
I don't ever
go in my history.
We will be running
a short scan
in your computer
to check and see
what the problem is
and how we're able
to fix up this issue, okay?
Okay.
Sir, are you sure
you want us to help you out
or you're joking with us?
Oh, no.
I'm not joking.
I need you
to help me out.
I don't think so
because you don't sound
like you want us
to fix up the issue
or something.
It's just
that you're joking.
Well, I'm not joking.
What suggests
that I'm joking?
Der Scammer merkt,
dass er gescampt wird.
I've genuinely
received a pop-up.
Which is not showing
in my history
for whatever reason.
And I don't know
why I received it.
Sorry?
Which website
were you on
when it came up?
I was trying
to go to Facebook.
Do you visit any
adult pornographic websites?
Often.
In fact, all the time.
At least every day.
So that might be
the result of it.
I'm not sure
because I've heard
about viruses
from porn websites before.
That's not a virus.
These are unwanted
phishing and hacking links
and trojans
that I bought
into your computer.
Right, okay.
Well, that doesn't sound good.
Mm-hmm.
Hacking links.
What's a hacking link?
Mm-hmm.
When people try
to hack into your information.
Right.
Well, that doesn't sound good.
So I'm gonna run
and start scanning you.
Der Scam-Tuber
hat echt Probleme.
Er ist eigentlich
noch so bedient.
Er kriegt es nicht gemacht.
Computer,
which will scan
the entire security.
Okay.
Detect what the issue is
and help you out, okay?
All right.
So after we're able
to fix up the issue
and repair the security
and take care of things.
You can see here
there's a whole page
of legitimate programs.
What are you using
for the payment?
Is it a VISA,
a master RAM,
it's just covered?
It will be a VISA card.
What do you basically do
on the computer normally?
I do some work,
various different
web surfing tasks.
It's just a sort
of all purpose machine.
That's where
I write stuff.
Which version
of this is?
I'm honestly
not sure.
It's a Windows version.
As I said before,
I'm not too sure
what version.
So we can help you
and check and see
whatever it is
and resolve the problem.
Right, okay.
So,
okay.
well,
depending on the level
of corruption,
all you need to let me know
is for how long
do you want us to upgrade
the security for?
Shall it be for a year,
two years,
three years?
For how long?
Well,
is three years
the best option,
do you think?
Well,
yes it is.
It can be.
Right, okay.
I think I'll go
for three years then.
Well,
for three years
it's going to cost you
around about $399.99.
What?
And how will I,
will I be using
a payment form
where you need to fill up
everything
and do everything
from your end?
Right, okay.
I don't think so.
Are you sure about
what you're talking about?
Are you sure?
Are you sure you know
what you're talking about?
I mean,
come on,
you're telling me
that you need to upgrade
the security.
Ah,
da jetzt hat er entlarvt.
Das ist ja langweilig.
Ich dachte,
der Inder klickt noch
ein bisschen,
ein bisschen rum und
on this channel
very shortly.
Shit.
Ja,
das ist ja doof.
Ich dachte,
Okay,
das gucken wir
jetzt nochmal an.
Okay,
den gucken wir
jetzt nochmal an
und dann,
dann gehe ich
was futtern.
Okay.
Do not click
on redeem.
Once you're done,
after typing
the number,
you say me,
I am done.
What?
Das hat
irgendwie
einen komischen
voice changer.
Das geht mir
immer voll auf den Sack,
wenn Leute
sagen,
I am done.
Okay?
Oh,
okay.
oh,
I am
done.
Moment,
was?
Oh,
oh,
I am
done.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
Okay,
And now,
I hiding
that.
Okay.
Okay,
the app
just
偏
The Android
that that
one
that
I
thought
Da ist er immer ein bisschen sprachlos.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich
ein Fake-Google-Store
oder sowas.
Lustig.
Den kenne ich gar nicht.
Das sagt mir überhaupt nichts, der Channel.
Ich finde, da muss ich mal gucken.
Der hat bestimmt noch mehr cooles Zeug.
Habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Aber es gibt eh viele lustige Scam-Videos,
wo die Scammer gescampt werden am Ende.
Ja, Leute.
Also, irgendwie
2,5 Stunden waren da gewesen.
Absolut nichts gemacht
heute. Absolut gar nichts.
Mal gucken.
Gibt es jemanden hier, der online ist, den man hosten kann?
Der Race ist aber
auch sauaktiv hier.
Der Name sagt mir nur was,
weil der hat immer irgendwas bei Cloud9 oder so
gemacht. Linux weiter
einrichten. Ah, wen haben wir da?
Diese Pop-Ups, die gehen mir
auf Twitch so ultra auf den Sack.
Moment, was?
Schneewittchen und die 7 Geilen.
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler.
Ein Zuschauer wieder. 3D.
Printer. Es gibt in Deutschland
nichts unter Science und Technology.
Es ist ja kein Wunder, dass ich immer Viewer kriege.
Wonka BWL.
Kein Wunder, dass ich immer Viewer kriege.
Ist ja sonst keiner da.
So quasi alternativlos.
Okay, Leute. Ich muss unbedingt
was futtern. Ich habe mega Hunger.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Mal gucken. Wahrscheinlich
sehen wir uns morgen.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
CU.
Moment. Erst mal gucken.
Leute, wartet mal. Gucken. Ich glaube, ich habe
Prime-Subscriber vergessen.
Ich habe Prime-Subscriber vergessen.
Recent Events.
Ne, habe ich nicht vergessen.
Gut.
Man kann bei der
Gelegenheit nochmal Sellout machen. Übrigens, falls ihr einen Amazon
Prime-Account habt.
Amazon Prime ist ja verbreitet. Wer hat
heute eigentlich keinen Amazon Prime-Account? Könnt
ihr euren Amazon Prime-Account kostenlos
mit eurem Twitch-Account verknüpfen.
Und da bekommt ihr quasi monatlich
kostenloses Twitch Prime-Loot und
ihr könnt einen
Streamer eurer Wahl
mit einem Sub unterstützen.
Das Ganze kostet euch nichts und das Streamer hat
alle Vorteile davon, die ihr von einem normalen
Sub kriegen würde, ohne dass
ihr da was extra für bezahlen müsst.
Ist das nicht nice? Twitch Prime.
Beste.
Dauerwerbesendung. Ja, zum Schluss
kann man nochmal eine Runde Sellout machen.
Okay, Leute. Genug Sellout
gemacht.
Ich muss jetzt echt was essen. Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
See you.